You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
你知道，你的眼睛承受了很多压力。每天阅读、在昏暗的灯光下工作、长时间盯着屏幕——这种情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光，甚至夜间驾驶都会导致视疲劳。所以，没错，我们的眼睛负担很重。因此，通过定期的眼科检查来呵护它们并监测其健康状况非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行眼科检查，费用仅需 99 美元起，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段发现眼部和健康状况。要查找您附近的门店并预约眼科检查，请访问
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. Welcome to our second drink of the deposition. Jenna, we talk a lot about ping pong and a lot about journals in this episode. Well, we also talked about how much water Tom Brady drinks and we wondered where and how football players go to pee? Well, thanks to Amanda S from Salisbury, North Carolina, we might have an answer. Amanda says football players definitely pee on the sidelines into cups. If you've ever sat behind the bench, you see it happen. Come on.
OCT 扫描费用 99 美元起，请访问 specksavers.ca。眼科检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。欢迎来到我们关于“取证”这一集的第二次畅饮。珍娜，我们在这一集中谈了很多关于乒乓球和日志的内容。嗯，我们还谈到了汤姆·布雷迪喝多少水，我们很好奇足球运动员在哪里以及如何撒尿？好吧，多亏了北卡罗来纳州索尔兹伯里的阿曼达·S，我们可能有了答案。阿曼达说，足球运动员肯定是在场边对着杯子撒尿。如果你曾经坐在替补席后面，你就会看到这种情况。拜托。
Usually they use their big coats draped over them and they turn toward the field or they use each other to maintain privacy. I've sat behind the bench at NFL games many a time. And while I know what's going on, I've never seen penises just flying around. Laughing face emoji. Wow. I mean, you do see them in those big giant warming coats. So they're peeing?
通常他们会用大外套披在身上，然后转向球场，或者利用彼此来保持隐私。我曾多次坐在 NFL 比赛的替补席后面。虽然我知道发生了什么，但我从未见过阴茎到处乱飞。（笑脸表情）哇。我的意思是，你确实在那些巨大的保暖外套里看到过它们。所以他们是在撒尿？
Sometimes, not all the time. But it's like, you know, when you're camping and you got to go pee and like your friend holds up a towel that you squat behind, same principle. Yeah. Just not with thousands of people right behind you. Exactly. Well, a whole lot of people said, Angie is not making up a song.
有时是这样，但不是一直。但这就像，你知道，当你露营时需要撒尿，你的朋友举起一条毛巾让你蹲在后面，原理是一样的。是的。只是身后没有成千上万的人。完全正确。好吧，很多人说，安吉并没有编造那首歌。
It's Avril Levine's song Girlfriend. I literally can't believe I didn't catch that. I mean, I know that song. It is on multiple playlists of mine. I know it too. I don't know what I was thinking. Anyway, I went to the shooting draft. I wanted to see how it was written into the scene.
那是艾薇儿·拉维尼的歌《Girlfriend》。我简直不敢相信我没听出来。我的意思是，我知道那首歌。它在我的多个播放列表中。我也知道。我不知道我在想什么。总之，我看了拍摄草稿。我想看看它是如何被写进场景的。
As written in the script, Daryl serves. Jim gets a piece of it, but it goes flying off to the side. Kelly does a little dance. Kelly sings a la Ava Levine's girlfriend. Hey, hey, you, I don't like your boyfriend. You shouldn't either because he sucks at ping pong.
按照剧本，达里尔发球。吉姆接到了，但球飞到了旁边。凯利跳了一小段舞。凯利唱着艾薇儿·拉维尼的《Girlfriend》。嘿，嘿，你，我不喜欢你的女朋友。你也不应该喜欢，因为他乒乓球打得很烂。
Okay, Pam's like, oh, fine. Here are the alts, ready? Kelly, a la Justin Timberlake, sexy back. Hey, Pam, your boyfriend sucks at ping pong. My boyfriend, Daryl's bringing ping pong back. Okay? I'm so sorry, I shouldn't be the one saying this. Here's another alt.
好吧，帕姆说，哦，好吧。这是备选方案，准备好了吗？凯利，模仿贾斯汀·汀布莱克的《SexyBack》。嘿，帕姆，你男朋友乒乓球打得很烂。我男朋友，达里尔正在让乒乓球回归。好吗？我很抱歉，我不该说这些。这是另一个备选方案。
Kelly taunts Pam, a la la the song, bad day. Well, you had a bad day. Your boyfriend is lame. You got your ass kicked and you had a bad day. Anyway, then lastly, Kelly taunts, Pam, a la my boyfriend's back. My boyfriend's great and he beat your lame boyfriend. Hey, now, you know, your boyfriend lost. I feel like they just had fun in the writer's room.
凯利嘲讽帕姆，模仿歌曲《Bad Day》。好吧，你度过了糟糕的一天。你男朋友很逊。你被踢了屁股，你度过了糟糕的一天。总之，最后，凯利嘲讽帕姆，模仿《My Boyfriend's Back》。我男朋友很棒，他打败了你那个逊毙了的男朋友。嘿，现在，你知道，你男朋友输了。我觉得他们在编剧室里玩得很开心。
We did not need four alts on this. And I'm telling you, I'm sure Mindy crushed all of those. Although maybe we did. Maybe it was one of those things where we didn't have the musical permission when we shot. So we had to do a bunch of alts to cover our butts. Yeah. I bet that's it. I bet so too.
我们不需要四个备选方案。我敢说，明迪肯定把这些都写得很棒。虽然也许我们需要。也许是因为我们拍摄时没有音乐版权。所以我们不得不做一堆备选方案来保护自己。是的。我敢打赌就是这样。我也这么认为。
Well, we also got this question about Kelly's runner of trash talking about Jim from Nicole in Montreal. Nicole says, I know the writers would write a lot of different options for characters' lines. And I was wondering if Kelly had candy bag alts for her. insults about Jim. Oh, Nicole, Nicole, I found a whole page of them. There were so many. So I'm just going to read you a few. In the actual episode, Kelly says, what has two skinny chicken legs and sucks at ping pong? Here are some of the alts. Your boyfriend's so pasty, they use them to put up wallpaper. Your boyfriend's so skinny, he needs snowshoes just to walk across a storm train. So silly. So specific. I know. Your boyfriend's
好吧，我们还收到了来自蒙特利尔的妮可关于凯利嘲讽吉姆的连珠炮的问题。妮可说，我知道编剧会为角色的台词写很多不同的选项。我想知道凯利是否有关于侮辱吉姆的备选方案。哦，妮可，妮可，我找到了一整页。有太多了。所以我只读几个给你听。在实际剧集中，凯利说，什么东西有两条瘦弱的鸡腿，而且乒乓球打得很烂？以下是一些备选方案。你男朋友太苍白了，他们用他来贴墙纸。你男朋友太瘦了，他需要雪鞋才能走过暴风雨。太傻了。太具体了。我知道。你男朋友
so bad in bed. What he lacks for in size, he makes up for in speed. That's really. Wow. Here's the last one. Jim's so weak, he needs forceps to find his biceps and triceps. Okay. Okay. Well, Ann, in this episode, Jan gives Michael's journal to her lawyer and they read from it. It's so wonderful. They also make copies of it and everyone's reading it at lunch. Well, we got a question sent in by Margaret B from New Mexico. She says, ladies, loved your breakdown of the deposition. I'm curious, if you were at someone's house and came across their journal, would you take a peek and read a little?
在床上太差劲了。他缺乏尺寸，但他用速度来弥补。那真是。哇。这是最后一个。吉姆太虚弱了，他需要镊子才能找到他的二头肌和三头肌。好吧。好吧。嗯，安，在这一集中，简把迈克尔的日志给了她的律师，他们读了里面的内容。太精彩了。他们还复印了它，午餐时每个人都在读。好吧，我们收到了来自新墨西哥州的玛格丽特·B发来的问题。她说，女士们，喜欢你们对“取证”这一集的解析。我很好奇，如果你在某人家里偶然发现了他们的日志，你会偷看并读一点吗？
Would you have read Michael's journal? My answer is no. I have like a real strong boundary about people's privacy. I would never read somebody's journal. Let me ask you this. If the journal was open to a page, just, sitting on the desk and it's open and you're just like, oh, I need to grab a pen and then you look and you see this open journal. Would you read it? Or would you quickly avert your eyes?
你会读迈克尔的日志吗？我的回答是不会。我对人们的隐私有很强的界限感。我永远不会读别人的日志。让我问你这个。如果日志翻开着，就放在桌子上，它是打开的，你就像，哦，我需要拿一支笔，然后你一看，看到了这本打开的日志。你会读吗？还是你会迅速移开视线？
I would quickly avert my eyes. I'm that way about people's text messages, about people's photos. Like if someone's like, oh, I want to show you this picture and they get out their phone and they start scrolling their photos, I avert my eyes just on the off chance that there's a photo in their scroll that might be embarrassing to them or that they wouldn't intend for me to see. I wait for them to pull up the photo. And you know what else I don't do? I don't swipe. If someone is like, oh, here's, I want to show you pictures from Hawaii. And they show me a picture from Hawaii. I do not swipe to the next picture. I'm not going to just start swiping someone's phone. I don't start willy-nilly swiping. But if there was someone like Michael Scott in my life,
我会迅速移开视线。我对人们的短信、照片也是这样。比如如果有人说，哦，我想给你看这张照片，然后他们拿出手机开始翻看照片，我会移开视线，以防万一他们翻动时有让他们尴尬的照片，或者他们不打算让我看到的照片。我等他们调出照片。你知道我还不做什么吗？我不滑动。如果有人说，哦，这是，我想给你看夏威夷的照片。然后他们给我看了一张夏威夷的照片。我不会滑动到下一张照片。我不会开始随意滑动别人的手机。我不随意滑动。但如果我生命中有像迈克尔·斯科特这样的人，
not just anyone. Okay. I think this is a case-by-case scenario. scenario. Okay. If there's a Michael Scott in my life and I'm in his house for whatever reason. And his journal is open. And his journal is open. And it's by the pen you need. I'm going to read it. Okay. I'm going to read it. I'm not going to take a picture of it. I'm going to read it. And then I'm going to tell all my friends about it. Okay. Fair enough. But not like a nice person. But like if I'm in your house and there's something on your desk, I'm not going to look at that. I'm not going to look at that. Even if you need a pen, that's right next to it and it's open. Even if I need a pen, I will just block it with my hand as I reach
不只是任何人。好吧。我认为这是一个具体情况具体分析的场景。好吧。如果我生命中有迈克尔·斯科特，而我因为某种原因在他家里。他的日志是打开的。他的日志是打开的。它就在你需要的那支笔旁边。我会读的。好吧。我会读的。我不会拍照片。我会读的。然后我会告诉所有的朋友。好吧。有道理。但不是像个好人那样。但如果我在你家里，你桌上有东西，我不会看那个。我不会看那个。即使你需要一支笔，它就在旁边，而且是打开的。即使我需要一支笔，我也会用手挡住它，当我伸手
across for the pin. But if it's a Michael Scott-esque person, you might need to. I might need to look at it. Okay. That's fine. Okay. Anyway, that's a very interesting question. I'm not a snoop lady. If it's out there in my face, I'm going to look at it. And who can blame you? Thank you. Lastly, you guys, I found a great talking head by Toby and the candy bag alts. It would have come right after they read from Michael's journal in the deposition. And here's what it said. I think it's so damn funny. Toby looks directly to the camera crew. God bless you. God bless you for recording this today for all time. That does make me laugh. All right, everybody, here is our breakdown of the deposition. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends.
去拿笔的时候。但如果是迈克尔·斯科特那样的人，你可能需要。我可能需要看一眼。好吧。没关系。好吧。总之，这是一个非常有趣的问题。我不是个爱打听的人。如果它就在我面前，我会看的。谁能怪你呢？谢谢。最后，伙计们，我找到了托比的一段很棒的谈话头和备选方案。它本应该出现在取证中他们读迈克尔日志之后。它是这样说的。我觉得太搞笑了。托比直接看着摄像组。上帝保佑你们。上帝保佑你们今天把这一切记录下来，留给后世。这确实让我笑了。好了，各位，这就是我们对“取证”的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello, everybody. Good morning. Today is very important. We have to do a very important legal procedure. Oh, Lord.
现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将解析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。早上好。今天非常重要。我们必须进行一项非常重要的法律程序。哦，天哪。
I was like, wait, what's happening? And then I realized you're talking about the episode. The deposition. I was like, Jenna, what do we have to do? Did I miss an email? What's happening? No. We have a very important deposition today, Angela. It's season four, episode 12. Written by Lester Lewis, directed by Julian Farino. Hit me with a summary. Here it is. Michael and Jan go to corporate, and Michael is deposed as a witness in Jan's wrongful termination case against Dunder Mifflin. What was Jan thinking? Why would you ever put Michael on any
我当时想，等等，发生了什么？然后我意识到你在谈论这一集。取证。我当时想，珍娜，我们必须做什么？我错过了一封邮件吗？发生了什么？不。安吉拉，我们今天有一个非常重要的取证。这是第四季第 12 集。由莱斯特·刘易斯编剧，朱利安·法里诺执导。给我一个总结。在这里。迈克尔和简去公司，迈克尔作为简对邓德·米夫林不当解雇诉讼中的证人出庭。简在想什么？你为什么要把迈克尔放在任何
kind of witness stand. I don't know. I'm so glad she did. Well, while they're gone, Jim and Daryl play ping pong in the warehouse, which sparks a rivalry between Pam and Kelly. Fast fact number one this week, Angela, is Lester Lewis, the writer of this episode. Before writing on the office, Lester had worked on the Larry Sanders show and Caroline in the city. He was one of the original members of our writing team going back to season one. And this is a tough one for me, and for both of us I know, Lester passed away in 2013. And I don't even know where to start. I loved him. I loved this man. We bonded over our love of autobiographical comic books. We both loved those. And I just have such fun memories of being with him. And he was
证人席上。我不知道。我很高兴她这么做了。好吧，当他们离开时，吉姆和达里尔在仓库里打乒乓球，这引发了帕姆和凯利之间的竞争。本周第一个速记，安吉拉，是莱斯特·刘易斯，这一集的编剧。在为《办公室》编剧之前，莱斯特曾在《拉里·桑德斯秀》和《卡罗琳在城市》工作过。他是我们编剧团队的原始成员之一，可以追溯到第一季。这对我和我们俩来说都是艰难的，我知道，莱斯特于 2013 年去世了。我甚至不知道从哪里开始。我爱他。我爱这个人。我们因对自传体漫画书的热爱而结缘。我们都喜欢那些。我对他有非常美好的回忆。他
so funny and he was so just kind and warm. He was so kind and just a good, good person. And I miss him. Yeah, I mean, Lester was someone that made time for everyone. You know those people? They make time for everybody. And he was just a wonderful part of our show. I re-listened to the DVD commentary for this particular episode. Lester is in the commentary. And it was so wonderful to hear his voice. And also made me sad. It was bittersweet. But if you listen to the DVD commentary for this episode, you will just hear what a thoughtful person he was. And I'll share a few of the things that he said on the commentary as we record today, Jenna. I love that. Well, lady, what is your fast fact number two? You know, ping pong features very heavily in this episode. So I felt we needed a little history of ping pong. Oh my gosh. Did someone do a deep dive on ping pong? I did. I want you to know it has two other names. Oh, table tennis or whiffwaffe. Whiffwaffe? That sounds made up.
太有趣了，他非常善良和温暖。他非常善良，是一个真正的好人。我怀念他。是的，我的意思是，莱斯特是一个为每个人腾出时间的人。你知道那些人吗？他们为每个人腾出时间。他是我们节目中非常棒的一部分。我重听了这一集的 DVD 评论。莱斯特在评论中。听到他的声音真是太好了。也让我感到难过。这是苦乐参半的。但如果你听这一集的 DVD 评论，你会听到他是一个多么体贴的人。当我们今天录音时，我会分享他在评论中所说的一些事情，珍娜。我喜欢那样。好吧，女士，你的第二个速记是什么？你知道，乒乓球在这一集中占有重要地位。所以我认为我们需要一点乒乓球的历史。哦，天哪。有人深入研究了乒乓球吗？我研究了。我想让你知道它还有两个名字。哦，乒乓球或 Whiff Waff。Whiff Waff？听起来像是编出来的。
Do you want to play some whiff waff? I'll play you some wuffle whiff waff. Oh, dear. I'll chunk it at you. What else you got about ping pong? Ping pong began in Victorian England. I know you'll like the sound of that, Angela, in the 1880s. When lawn tennis players adapted their game to play indoors during the winter. Oh.
你想玩点 Whiff Waff 吗？我会陪你玩点 Whiff Waff。哦，亲爱的。我会把它扔给你。关于乒乓球你还有什么？乒乓球起源于维多利亚时代的英国。我知道你会喜欢这个声音，安吉拉，在 1880 年代。当时草地网球运动员改编了他们的游戏，以便在冬天在室内玩。哦。
Where's my Netflix show about that? Right. Whiff Wif-Waff, episode one. The Duke of Edinburgh comes to play Wif-Waff. The game quickly caught on in as early as 1901 tournaments were being conducted with over 300 participants. In 1902, a visiting Japanese university professor took the game back to Japan, where he introduced it to Japanese university students. The first world championships were held in London in 1927. They were won by a Hungarian.
我的 Netflix 关于那个的节目在哪里？对。Whiff Waff，第一集。爱丁堡公爵来玩 Whiff Waff。这项运动很快流行起来，早在 1901 年，就有超过 300 名参与者的锦标赛。1902 年，一位来访的日本大学教授将这项运动带回了日本，并将其介绍给了日本大学生。第一届世界锦标赛于 1927 年在伦敦举行。冠军是一位匈牙利人。
Dr. Jacoby. Congratulations. Dr. Jacoby. You go to see him for a checkup, but little do you know, he's a ping pong master. That's right. The Olympic Games started featuring ping pong for the first time in 1988 in Seoul. The television coverage of the men's singles final attracted a worldwide audience of two billion. Wow. Yeah. Here was something I found very interesting. There are many different ways to grip the
雅各比博士。恭喜。雅各比博士。你去看他做检查，但你不知道，他是一位乒乓球大师。没错。奥运会于 1988 年在首尔首次将乒乓球列入比赛项目。男子单打决赛的电视转播吸引了全球 20 亿观众。哇。是的。这是我发现非常有趣的一点。握拍有很多种方式
paddle and all of those grips have names. Oh gosh. Here's how you can hold it. You can give it the old penhold, the shake hand, or the Seamiller. The Seamiller is actually named after an American table tennis champ Danny Seamiller because that's how he held his paddle. He puts his little finger out. That's what she said. There are also a bunch of different strokes. Oh, gosh. That's what she said. Oh, Lord. There are offensive strokes. The hit, the loop, the counter hit, the flip, the smash. Then there's defensive strokes called the push, the chop, the block, and the lob. And the biggest part of the game, the biggest thing that these guys work on is their spin. And you can do a top spin, a back spin, a side spin, and a cork spin.
球拍，所有这些握法都有名字。哦，天哪。这是你可以握住它的方式。你可以用老式的直拍、横拍或 Seamiller。Seamiller 实际上是以美国乒乓球冠军丹尼·西米勒的名字命名的，因为他就是那样握球拍的。他把小指伸出来。这就是她说的。还有一堆不同的击球方式。哦，天哪。这就是她说的。哦，天哪。有进攻性击球。扣杀、拉球、反击、翻挑、扣杀。然后有防守性击球，称为推挡、削球、挡球和高球。游戏最大的部分，这些人最努力练习的是他们的旋转。你可以做上旋、下旋、侧旋和侧旋。
Do you remember how good Forrest Gump was at Pingpong? Yeah. He was so good. I wonder if he was using the Similer. Maybe the pen hold. I don't know. I think you do know that my husband turned our beautiful dining table into a ping pong table. Lady, I know this.
你还记得阿甘在乒乓球方面有多厉害吗？是的。他太厉害了。我想知道他是否用了 Seamiller。也许是直拍。我不知道。我想你知道我丈夫把我们漂亮的餐桌变成了乒乓球桌。女士，我知道这一点。
I watched this happen, and I knew you were going to regret it. You guys were real excited, and I thought, that's going to come back. They haven't regretted it, Jenna. There's only one person that regrets it. Can we explain what Angela did, guys? Here's what her family did. They got one of these ping pong table tops that fits over her kitchen table. It's meant to go over a pool table, right?
我看着这一切发生，我知道你会后悔的。你们当时真的很兴奋，我想，那会回来的。他们没有后悔，珍娜。只有一个后悔的人。我们可以解释安吉拉做了什么吗，伙计们？这是她家人做的。他们买了一个可以放在她餐桌上的乒乓球桌面。它本来是放在台球桌上的，对吧？
Oh. It's meant to set on top of a pool table and you just put it on top of your dining table. Of course, it doesn't fit our dining table, so it hangs off. Well, also now, guys, she has nowhere to eat. Okay? Angela, this is now your dining table. It's just, it's so, I don't know. Josh and the kids love it.
哦。它本来是放在台球桌上的，你只要把它放在餐桌上就行了。当然，它不适合我们的餐桌，所以它悬在外面。好吧，而且现在，伙计们，她没地方吃饭了。好吗？安吉拉，这现在是你的餐桌了。它只是，它太，我不知道。乔希和孩子们很喜欢它。
What I didn't factor in, I knew I'd be eating like awkwardly for the rest of our time. But what I didn't factor in was the bouncing ball sound. Mm-hmm. I'm talking at like 8 a.m. because they want to play a game before school starts. Mm-hmm. You know? So it's like, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank.
我没考虑到的是，我知道我会在余下的时间里尴尬地吃饭。但我没考虑到的是弹球的声音。嗯。我说的是早上 8 点左右，因为他们想在上学前玩一场游戏。嗯。你知道吗？所以就像，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰。
bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang. It is nonstop. Yeah. You come down the stairs. Bang, bang, bang, bang, bang. It doesn't matter what time. You've got that, and then all your appliances are beeping. Oh, don't get me started.
砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰。它是没完没了的。是的。你走下楼梯。砰，砰，砰，砰，砰。什么时间都不重要。你有那个，然后你所有的电器都在发出哔哔声。哦，别让我开始。
It's so much noise. Anyway, here's an interesting tidbit from the commentary. Jenna, I know how much you love the wall in the writer's room with all the note cards, right? Yeah. All the different possible story ideas. That's one of my favorite things to go look at at my lunch. Well, Lester shared, there was one for this episode that didn't get used, simply written it was Dwight gets stuck in the wall. So if we didn't have this ping pong competition, the other thing that might have happened is that Dwight was going to get stuck in a wall.
噪音太大了。总之，这是评论中的一个有趣的小花絮。珍娜，我知道你有多喜欢编剧室里那面贴满便签纸的墙，对吧？是的。所有不同的可能故事创意。那是我午餐时最喜欢去看的东西之一。好吧，莱斯特分享说，这一集有一个没被用上的，简单地写着：德怀特被卡在墙里。所以如果我们没有这个乒乓球比赛，另一件可能发生的事情是德怀特会被卡在墙里。
Yeah. That was going to be Dwight's storyline. Instead of helping Jim or the ping pong, I don't know how it would have played out. Ultimately, they couldn't make it work in this episode. Oh, man, I have to say I love this ping pong story. I also would have loved to have seen whatever that was going to be. How would he have gotten in the wall? How would he have got stuck in there?
是的。那本来是德怀特的故事情节。而不是帮助吉姆或乒乓球，我不知道它会如何发展。最终，他们无法在这一集中实现它。哦，伙计，我必须说我喜欢这个乒乓球故事。我也很想看到那会是什么样子。他怎么会进墙里？他怎么会被卡在那里？
I was laughing so hard when they were talking about it. That is some good stuff. All right. Fast fact number three is all about the writer's strike. Oh. Mm-hmm. This was the last. episode of the Office that we shot before the Writers Guild of America went on strike and we had to
当他们谈论它时，我笑得太厉害了。那是一些好东西。好吧。第三个速记是关于编剧罢工的。哦。嗯。这是《办公室》在编剧协会罢工前拍摄的最后一集，我们不得不
shut down production. Now, this was really significant, guys, because NBC ordered 30 episodes for Season 4 of the Office. 30. Wow. This was a huge episode order. You know, typical seasons are like 22 to 24 episodes long. But then, in November 2007, the Writers Guild went on strike. So if I remember correctly, Angela, we were allowed to shoot any outstanding scripts, but there could be no new writing done, and we could not have a writer on set with us. Exactly. No writers were showing up to work, period. Well, we really relied on our writers to be on set with us while we were shooting. That was a big part of our process on the show, is they would pitch alternates, and they were so important to the show being great. And not only that, three of them were also actors. And Steve Carell was a member,
关闭制作。现在，这非常重要，伙计们，因为 NBC 为《办公室》第四季预订了 30 集。30。哇。这是一个巨大的剧集订单。你知道，典型的季节大约是 22 到 24 集。但后来，在 2007 年 11 月，编剧协会罢工了。所以如果我没记错的话，安吉拉，我们被允许拍摄任何未完成的剧本，但不能进行新的写作，我们也不能让编剧和我们一起在片场。没错。没有编剧来上班，句号。好吧，我们确实依赖我们的编剧在拍摄时和我们在一起。这是我们在节目中过程的重要组成部分，他们会提出备选方案，他们对节目的成功非常重要。不仅如此，其中三个人也是演员。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是
of the Writers Guild Union, and he would not cross the picket line for work. That's right. And I know that meant a lot to our writers that he stood with them. Yes. So we shut down. And any unused scripts were just tabled, and the strike lasted over three months. Yes. And for those of you that are on the old Preggers belly, the Kinsey Preggers Belly, this was really weird because I left work not really showing and just wait for dinner party. Well, Angela, you also went out with some of the other actors and you picketed, I remember. I did. I went over and I picketed with our writers. And I remember Ed was there the day that I went. And it was very bonding experience. The Writers Guild wasn't asking for the moon. They were just asking for really just basic, decent, fair treatment from studios. And I was really happy to help get their voices heard in any way that I could.
编剧协会工会的成员，他不会越过纠察线去工作。没错。我知道这对我们的编剧来说意义重大，他与他们站在一起。是的。所以我们关闭了。任何未使用的剧本都被搁置了，罢工持续了三个多月。是的。对于你们那些老孕妇，金赛孕妇，这真的很奇怪，因为我离开工作时并没有真正显怀，只是等待晚宴。好吧，安吉拉，你也和其他一些演员一起去纠察了，我记得。我去了。我过去和我们的编剧一起纠察。我记得我去的那天埃德也在。这是一种非常团结的经历。编剧协会并没有要求月亮。他们只是要求工作室提供真正基本的、体面的、公平的待遇。我很高兴能以任何方式帮助他们的声音被听到。
Well, we always appreciated our writers, but I'll tell you, Angela, you and I are writing a book right now. Ooh. And I will say, there is nothing harder than staring at a blank piece of paper and putting something on it. Yeah, I know. I think that writers have the hardest job in our industry. Because all the rest of us, we get to start with something. We get to build on something that already exists. But the writers have to manifest it from nothing.
好吧，我们一直很感激我们的编剧，但我告诉你，安吉拉，你和我现在正在写一本书。哦。我会说，没有什么比盯着一张空白的纸并把东西写在上面更难的了。是的，我知道。我认为编剧是我们行业中最困难的工作。因为我们其余的人，我们从某样东西开始。我们可以在已经存在的东西上进行构建。但编剧必须从无到有地创造它。
Well, yeah, I know after the office, I went into development, as you know, Jenna. I wrote and I sold pilots and it was so hard because not only do you write this thing that you love, it becomes your baby, then you have to hand it over to like studio heads and network and they have all these notes and they just carve it up and you're like, my baby! Yeah, guys, we love our writers. Yep. And a lot of people always ask, why was season four of the office so much shorter than the others? And that is why? Because of the right. We made fewer episodes that year. Well, Jenna, we were very lucky because our shows survived the writer's strike. We both had many friends who were actors and writers and producers who were on shows and the strike went on for so long that they weren't able to resume. So we were actually really fortunate. Yeah. Well, there you go, guys. Lady, that's all I got. I have a fun little thing. It's not a fast fact. Maybe it's a Kinsey titbit. What is it? Jenna, do you remember that Ed would do an impression of Tom Brokaw. Yes.
好吧，是的，我知道在《办公室》之后，我进入了开发阶段，正如你所知，珍娜。我写并卖出了试播集，这太难了，因为你不仅写了你喜欢的东西，它成了你的孩子，然后你必须把它交给工作室负责人和网络，他们有所有这些笔记，他们只是把它切开，你就像，我的孩子！是的，伙计们，我们爱我们的编剧。是的。很多人总是问，为什么《办公室》第四季比其他季节短得多？这就是原因。因为罢工。那一年我们制作的剧集更少了。好吧，珍娜，我们很幸运，因为我们的节目在编剧罢工中幸存了下来。我们都有许多朋友是演员、编剧和制片人，他们在节目中，罢工持续了太久，以至于他们无法恢复。所以我们实际上真的很幸运。是的。好吧，给你，伙计们。女士，这就是我所有的了。我有一个有趣的小东西。这不是速记。也许是金赛小花絮。是什么？珍娜，你还记得埃德会模仿汤姆·布罗考吗？是的。
And it would make us laugh. It was so good. It would make us laugh so hard. Okay. So what he would do is Ed as Tom Brokaw, he would start out telling a news story. And then he would tell us what our hot snack of the day was on set. And there was a particular time where we had albondagas soup. And he made that into part of Tom Brokaw's news announcement.
这会让我们发笑。太棒了。这会让我们笑得太厉害了。好吧。所以他会做的是埃德模仿汤姆·布罗考，他会开始讲一个新闻故事。然后他会告诉我们当天片场的今日热点零食是什么。有一次我们有肉丸汤。他把那个变成了汤姆·布罗考新闻公告的一部分。
And on the DVD commentary, they were talking about it. And Ed did it. Oh! Sam, will you play it? Could you give us the tombrokaw and say the magic word that makes Steve giggle? The Israelis have once again launched an all-bound-a-song on our Bondagon soup. That's what keeps us going. Nothing better on.
在 DVD 评论中，他们谈到了它。埃德做到了。哦！萨姆，你能播放它吗？你能给我们汤姆·布罗考的模仿，并说出那个让史蒂夫咯咯笑的魔词吗？以色列人再次对我们的肉丸汤发起了全面攻击。这就是让我们坚持下去的原因。没有什么比这更好的了。
Gosh, what a gem. I'm so happy that has been recorded. I know, I know. So if you guys want to know what behind the scenes moments were like, Ed was doing Tom Brokaw and John was doing impressions and we were all watching them and just cracking up. Oh my gosh, Angela, that actually brought tears of joy to my eyes. I know I'm very tired today and maybe that's made me a little emotional. But oh my goodness. Wow, that took me back. It did me too, Jenna. It just made me laugh and it warmed my heart. These were the behind the scenes moments that I treasure. Oh, all right. I'm going to let that take me into break. I'm going to pull myself together. We'll be right back.
天哪，真是个宝贝。我很高兴它被记录下来了。我知道，我知道。所以如果你们想知道幕后时刻是什么样的，埃德在模仿汤姆·布罗考，约翰在模仿，我们都在看着他们，笑得前仰后合。哦，天哪，安吉拉，那真的让我热泪盈眶。我知道我今天很累，也许这让我有点情绪化。但哦，天哪。哇，那把我带回去了。我也一样，珍娜。它只是让我笑了，温暖了我的心。这些是我珍视的幕后时刻。哦，好吧。我要让它带我进入休息时间。我要振作起来。我们马上回来。
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Because those really just add up. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. BetterHelp therapists can help.
本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，仅仅因为是新的一年，并不意味着你必须成为一个新的你。但也许你想成为一个负担较轻的你，一个更清晰的你。不是一个全新的你，但也许你只是想磨练一下。你想精炼。是的。我喜欢那个。精炼。好吧，治疗可以帮助更容易地识别是什么让你感到沉重，是什么可能阻碍了你。你可以更好地了解你的人际关系、你的动机、你的情绪。我正在努力放下对小事的压力。因为那些真的会累积起来。而且它们会没事的。好吧，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。BetterHelp 治疗师可以提供帮助。
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's large. largest online therapy platform having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-elp.com slash office ladies. Hi, this is Jill Schlesinger, CBS News, business analyst, certified financial planner, and the host of the Jill on Money podcast. With the new year upon us, there's no better time to take control of your
拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，BetterHelp 是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，在全球服务了超过 500 万人。BetterHelp 使在线匹配合格的治疗师变得容易。注册并在 betterhelp.com/officeladies 获得 10% 的折扣。那是 better, h-elp.com/officeladies。嗨，我是吉尔·施莱辛格，CBS 新闻商业分析师、认证理财规划师，也是 Jill on Money 播客的主持人。随着新年的到来，现在是掌控你
financial life and the Jill on Money podcast is here to help. It's your questions that make it possible for me to provide unconventional and I hope entertaining insights on your money, more importantly, on your life. Follow and listen to Jill on Money wherever you get your podcasts. All right, guys, we are back and Michael is in a series of very important meetings. The first meeting is with the accounting department. Seems very serious. Pam comes in. Hans Michael will post a note. Yes, and Michael says with great authority after reading the note, you know what, I need to just call them back. I can't talk right now. Everyone is very perplexed when he does this, by the way.
财务生活的最佳时机，Jill on Money 播客在这里提供帮助。正是你们的问题使我能够提供非传统的，我希望是娱乐性的见解，关于你的钱，更重要的是，关于你的生活。在任何你获取播客的地方关注并收听 Jill on Money。好吧，伙计们，我们回来了，迈克尔正在进行一系列非常重要的会议。第一次会议是与会计部门。看起来非常严肃。帕姆进来了。给迈克尔一张便签。是的，迈克尔在读完便签后非常有权威地说，你知道吗，我需要回电给他们。我现在不能说话。顺便说一句，当他这样做时，每个人都非常困惑。
Well, Pam explains in her talking head that Michael does not get a lot of phone calls, but one time he got a phone call and she interrupted him during a meeting with a Post-it note. And he was so delighted by this gesture that now he has asked her to do it every time he's in a meeting. But he doesn't get any calls, so she just makes it up. Yeah. Jenna, I would like to point out at 35 seconds, I'm titling this, happiness in the break room. Oh. I think this is the most functional moment we ever see Jan and Michael. They're eating lunch together. She is laughing at whatever he's saying. Pam brings in the note. He says, you know what? I'll have to call them back. She's impressed. I think this is peak Jan Michael happy moment. Yeah, you're right. They're being so functional. I know. Well, we had a fan question about this series of notes from Mariana W. Walter P., Philippa J, and Corinna O. Did Jenna make the sticky notes that Pam hands to Michael or were they made for her? Guys, I did not make any of the sticky notes. None of the words, none of the drawings are mine. And the very famous hiya buddy with the little hot dog that was actually drawn by our showrunner, Greg Dan.
好吧，帕姆在她的谈话头中解释说，迈克尔没有接到很多电话，但有一次他接到了一个电话，她在会议期间用一张便签打断了他。他对这个姿态感到非常高兴，以至于现在他要求她每次开会时都这样做。但他没有接到任何电话，所以她只是编造的。是的。珍娜，我想指出在 35 秒时，我将其命名为，休息室里的幸福。哦。我认为这是我们看到简和迈克尔最和谐的时刻。他们在一起吃午饭。她对他说的任何话都在笑。帕姆拿进便签。他说，你知道吗？我得回电给他们。她印象深刻。我认为这是简和迈克尔幸福时刻的巅峰。是的，你是对的。他们表现得非常和谐。我知道。好吧，我们收到了来自玛丽安娜·W、沃尔特·P、菲利帕·J 和科琳娜·O 关于这一系列便签的粉丝问题。是珍娜制作了帕姆交给迈克尔的便签，还是为她制作的？伙计们，我没有制作任何便签。没有文字，没有画是我做的。那个非常有名的“嗨，伙计”和那只小热狗实际上是我们节目制作人格雷格·丹尼尔斯画的。
Yes. Lester talked about it in the commentary and he said that Greg drew it just freehand quickly on their white message board, you know, in the writer's room. And then he had the props department come up and look at the drawing on the message board and they had to copy it and make it look just like the one on the message board. But then I heard they were not successful and so they just handed Greg a sticky note and he redid it himself. No, that I don't know. They tried. I I want to point out one thing, though, as the scene is happening between Michael and Ryan, and Pam is there. She's handed the note that says, hi, your buddy. And then Ryan's like, no, you should take the call.
是的。莱斯特在评论中谈到了它，他说格雷格只是在他们的白色留言板上快速徒手画的，你知道，在编剧室里。然后他让道具部门过来看看留言板上的画，他们必须复制它，让它看起来和留言板上的一模一样。但后来我听说他们没有成功，所以他们只是给了格雷格一张便签，他自己重做了。不，那个我不知道。他们试过了。我想指出一件事，虽然迈克尔和瑞安之间的场景正在发生，而帕姆在那里。她递给那张写着“嗨，伙计”的便签。然后瑞安说，不，你应该接那个电话。
Take the call. Yes. And Michael's like, no, you are my friend. I will not. And he's saying, I'm telling you, it's a work call. Take it. Jenna, your looks back and forth to Michael and Ryan in this moment. And then how you pick up the phone and you hit the extension and hand it to him.
接电话。是的。迈克尔说，不，你是我的朋友。我不会。他说，我告诉你，这是一个工作电话。接吧。珍娜，你此刻看着迈克尔和瑞安的眼神。然后你如何拿起电话，拨打分机并递给他。
It's so good. Your reactions made this scene for me. Oh, you're so not. I loved shooting that scene. It was so fun to watch them go back and forth. I loved the scenes where I got to just watch. You know what? That's who the audience is relating to because the audience is like, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God.
太棒了。你的反应为我成就了这个场景。哦，你太不是了。我喜欢拍摄那个场景。看着他们来回互动太有趣了。我喜欢那些我只需要观看的场景。你知道吗？这就是观众所共鸣的对象，因为观众就像，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，哦，天哪。
What's going to happen? What's happening? Well, next up, we are in the car with Jan and Michael. They're going somewhere. We find out they're on their way to New York City because Michael is going to be deposed in Jan's wrongful termination lawsuit. And we had a fan catch from Veronica Wright at 1 Minutes, 53 seconds, you can see that Jan has on flip-flops while she's driving the car.
会发生什么？发生了什么？好吧，接下来，我们和简和迈克尔在车里。他们要去某个地方。我们发现他们正在去纽约市的路上，因为迈克尔将在简的不当解雇诉讼中作证。我们在 1 分 53 秒收到了维罗妮卡·赖特的粉丝捕捉，你可以看到简在开车时穿着人字拖。
Oh, my God, really? Mm-hmm. Now, that's because, guys, Malora was really driving that car. You can see out the front window. We had a camera operator in the back, probably Randall Einhorn, capturing this. And so Malora was actually driving and performing. And, again, the PT Cruiser, because Michael's car is still in the shop, the Seabring. from when he drove it in the lake. Does he ever get it back? I guess we'll find out.
哦，天哪，真的吗？嗯。现在，这是因为，伙计们，马洛拉真的在开那辆车。你可以从前窗看到。我们在后面有一名摄像师，可能是兰德尔·艾因霍恩，捕捉到了这一点。所以马洛拉实际上是在开车和表演。而且，再次，PT Cruiser，因为迈克尔的车还在修理厂，赛布林。从他把它开进湖里开始。他还能拿回来吗？我想我们会发现的。
I don't know. This is our second episode where we see the PT Cruiser. Jan is coaching Michael on what to say. And Michael decides the best way to remember his testimony is to create very elaborate word associations. I wrote them all down. They're amazing. Here's Michael's shortcut to remembering things for this deposition. Jan says they displayed a pattern of disrespect and inappropriate behavior. Michael says, Pat turn. Pat earn. My friend Pat took a turn. Des Ray. My friend Desrey got new specs. Desray spec. My friend in a pro drives a preas with his behind neighbor. What? What? Yeah. And then Jan is like, does this really help you? And he's like, oh, yeah.
我不知道。这是我们看到 PT Cruiser 的第二集。简正在指导迈克尔该说什么。迈克尔决定记住他的证词的最好方法是创造非常复杂的词语联想。我把它们都写下来了。它们太棒了。这是迈克尔记住取证内容的捷径。简说他们表现出一种不尊重和不当行为的模式。迈克尔说，Pat turn。Pat earn。我的朋友 Pat 轮到了。Des Ray。我的朋友 Desrey 有了新眼镜。Desray spec。我的朋友在专业中开着一辆普锐斯，带着他的后邻居。什么？什么？是的。然后简说，这真的有帮助吗？他说，哦，是的。
We find out that Jan might win $4 million. That's a lot of guacamole. It sure is. Michael, though, is getting overwhelmed with the information that Jan is trying to get him to learn. Jan has a line that I thought was really funny. She's like, the truth is very complicated. So we had to go over it a few times. And Jenna, Michael needs the top down because he's going to puke.
我们发现简可能会赢得 400 万美元。那可是很多鳄梨酱。确实是。然而，迈克尔被简试图让他学习的信息淹没了。简有一句台词，我觉得非常有趣。她说，真相非常复杂。所以我们不得不复习几次。而且珍娜，迈克尔需要把车顶放下，因为他要吐了。
He's going to vomit. He's just getting too hot and flustered. Yes. Jan obligees, even though it completely messes up her hair. So now we're in the lobby of Corporate Dundermifflin, and we meet Jan's lawyer. Lester Schneider. He was played by Patrick O'Connor, who has also been in Christmas with the Cranks, Passions and Grey's Anatomy, among other things. Well, I have some very important plant alerts at corporate. Lay them on me. Three minutes 33 seconds, a big bamboo plant. Three minutes, 49 seconds, a white orchard. Orchid. Three minutes 53 seconds, a tree plant outside the front door. Three minutes 55 seconds. A pink orchid. What the heck? They have so many plants. It's corporate. They're fancy. They do. We had a fan question from Gary Kay, Sophia A, Libby B, and Marin B. Where were the corporate headquarters scenes filmed? They were just right on our warehouse stages. They built what is called a swing set. It's a little lingo coming at you. A little set lingo. So a swing set is something they build that they can put up and take down. And every time we had characters go to Dunder Mifflin corporate, they would bring out these walls and they had all their pictures to make sure they did it exactly the same every time.
他要呕吐了。他只是变得太热和慌乱了。是的。简顺从了，尽管这完全弄乱了她的头发。所以现在我们在邓德·米夫林公司的大厅里，我们见到了简的律师。莱斯特·施耐德。他由帕特里克·奥康纳饰演，他也曾出演过《圣诞快乐又疯狂》、《激情》和《实习医生格蕾》等。好吧，我在公司有一些非常重要的植物警报。告诉我。3 分 33 秒，一棵大竹子。3 分 49 秒，一棵白兰花。3 分 53 秒，前门外的一棵树。3 分 55 秒。一朵粉红色的兰花。搞什么鬼？他们有这么多植物。这是公司。他们很时髦。他们确实有。我们收到了来自加里·K、索菲亚·A、利比·B 和马林·B 的粉丝问题。公司总部场景是在哪里拍摄的？它们就在我们的仓库舞台上。他们建造了所谓的秋千布景。这是一个小行话。一点布景行话。所以秋千布景是他们建造的可以安装和拆卸的东西。每次我们有角色去邓德·米夫林公司时，他们都会拿出这些墙，他们有所有的照片，以确保他们每次都做得完全一样。
So they were just shooting right over in the Dunder Mifflin warehouse on a swing set. Lady, I have a little location breakdown for you about corporate. What is it? The corporate reception area with all the orchids and the plants also became the deposition room. Oh. Yeah, they only made one set. They set dressed it first for all the front reception scenes at corporate. And after all those scenes were done in the front reception area of corporate, they came in, set dressing, redid the whole room and made it into the deposition room. Well, there you go. So good. Well, location breakdown for you.
所以他们就在邓德·米夫林仓库的秋千布景上拍摄。女士，我有一个关于公司的地点解析给你。是什么？带有所有兰花和植物的公司接待区也变成了取证室。哦。是的，他们只做了一个布景。他们先为公司所有的前台场景进行了布景装饰。在公司前台区域的所有场景完成后，他们进来，重新装饰，重做了整个房间，把它变成了取证室。好吧，给你。太棒了。好吧，地点解析给你。
Location breakdown with Kinsey. Oh, well, Kinseypedia. Kinsa, Kinsa, Kinsipedia. Well, Jenna, at three minutes, 53 seconds, Ryan comes in. Flanked by two guys, right? Yep. Lester talks about this runner that the writers came up with that ultimately didn't get to be in an episode where Ryan only surrounds himself by guys that look like him but are shorter than him.
金赛的地点解析。哦，好吧，金赛百科。金萨，金萨，金赛百科。好吧，珍娜，在 3 分 53 秒，瑞安进来了。两边各有一个人，对吧？是的。莱斯特谈到了编剧们想出的这个连珠炮，最终没能出现在剧集中，瑞安只让看起来像他但比他矮的人围绕着他。
I remember this. Now, listen, Troy, he's the guy on the Blackberry. He's going to come back for a few other episodes. But this whole idea that he's surrounded by a posse of lookalikes but smaller but shorter, that never made it in, but Troy stayed. Back at Dunder Mifflin, Scranton, Jim and Daryl are playing ping pong in the warehouse. Pam explains that the warehouse got a ping pong table.
我记得这个。现在，听着，特洛伊，他是那个拿黑莓手机的人。他会回来参加其他几集。但这个他被一群长得像但更小更矮的人包围的想法，从未实现，但特洛伊留下了。回到邓德·米夫林，斯克兰顿，吉姆和达里尔在仓库里打乒乓球。帕姆解释说仓库里有一张乒乓球桌。
Jim comes down to play Daryl, and she sometimes brings him juice. That's what's going on. Well, apparently there was a big debate about these ping pong games. Should they CGI the ball, you know, in the game, or should they let you guys really play? Yep.
吉姆下来和达里尔打球，她有时会给他带果汁。这就是正在发生的事情。好吧，显然关于这些乒乓球比赛有一场大辩论。他们应该用 CGI 制作球，你知道，在游戏中，还是应该让你们真正玩？是的。
And they decided to let you guys really play And they talked about it in the commentary that this was kind of a disaster because you can't have continuity. Like they couldn't be sure that, you know, Craig as Darrell would hit it the same way every time or that John would hit it back the same way. And this little scene that you guys had at that beginning establishing ping pong game took like four hours. It was such a debacle. It was so insane. I also want to say Angela the ball makes noise. Mm-hmm.
他们决定让你们真的去玩，他们在评论音轨里谈到这简直是一场灾难，因为你们无法保持连贯性。比如他们无法确定，你知道的，克雷格饰演的达里尔每次都能以同样的方式击球，或者约翰每次都能以同样的方式回击。你们在开头建立乒乓球比赛的那个小场景花了大约四个小时。这真是一场惨败。太疯狂了。我还想说，安吉拉，球是有声音的。嗯。
And it would ping and Paul. on the table through our dialogue. Oh my gosh. That must have been so hard for the sound department because you guys are talking and then there's like bang, bank, bank, bank. And then it's probably bank banking at different times on different words every time, right? So anytime the camera comes a little tighter on me and Mindy, there was no ball, right? You might see some gestures from the guys, but they would try to get that clean sound because
它会在我们的对话中在桌子上发出乒乓声。天哪。这对音效部门来说一定很难，因为你们在说话，然后就有砰、砰、砰、砰的声音。而且每次在不同的词上发出的声音可能都不同，对吧？所以每当摄像机稍微拉近我和敏迪时，就没有球了，对吧？你可能会看到男士们的一些手势，但他们会尽量获得干净的声音，因为
pank bong, bank pong, pank, pank, pank, yeah. Yeah. It's going to ruin a scene. Well, Mindy has a line as Kelly that I loved when she said, I don't talk trash. I talk smack. They're totally different. I want to say I looked this up in Miriam Webster Dictionary. You looked up trash talk and smack talk? Mm-hmm. Oh, gosh. Here's what it says.
砰、乓、砰、乓、砰、砰、砰，是的。是的。这会毁了场景。嗯，敏迪作为凯利有一句台词我非常喜欢，她说：“我不说垃圾话。我说的是刻薄话。它们完全不同。”我想说我查了韦氏词典。你查了“垃圾话”和“刻薄话”？嗯。哦，天哪。它是这样说的。
Trash talk is defined as disparaging, taunting, or boastful comments, especially between opponents trying to intimidate each other. but do you know what it says when you get to smack talk? No. It says see Trash Talk. No, it does. Yes, it does. Which I kind of thought was a little bit of Smack Talk. I have to say.
“垃圾话”被定义为贬低、嘲讽或自夸的评论，特别是在试图恐吓对方的对手之间。但你知道当你查到“刻薄话”时它说什么吗？不知道。它说“参见垃圾话”。不，它真的说了。是的，它说了。我觉得这本身就有点像“刻薄话”。我不得不说。
The dictionary is like throwing shade at Trash Talk. Yeah. Smack Talk is trashing trash talk. Oh my gosh. Yes. I thought that was so funny. I also want to point out in the scene and throughout this episode, Jim's shirt, which he's untucked. It looks a lot like the one he wore to the convention. It also looks enormous.
字典就像是在对“垃圾话”进行讽刺。是的。“刻薄话”是在抨击“垃圾话”。天哪。是的。我觉得这太搞笑了。我还想指出在这个场景和整个这一集中，吉姆的衬衫，他没有塞进裤子里。看起来很像他去参加大会时穿的那件。看起来也巨大无比。
Yeah. It's like, I know this wasn't the 90s, but it could have been. Well, Jenna, there's going to be a moment where you get a real good shot of Pam's outfit. We'll get there. I have the time code. What's that supposed to mean? There's a lot of edge in your voice. I know. I had a lot of thoughts about this outfit. it. Jenna, did you know that this ping pong storyline was inspired by our writers, a real life? Yeah, they got a ping pong table down in the warehouse and those guys used to play all the time. Not only did they have a ping pong table in the warehouse, but the writers had made a ping pong table. Lee and Jean had made this ping pong table just using a regular table and kind of like what Pam does in the conference room. She makes this table. Well, the writers had done that before they got the actual ping pong table. So this is all inspired, like that Call of Duty storyline, by what was happening in our actual writer's room.
是的。就像，我知道这不是90年代，但完全可能是。嗯，珍娜，会有一个时刻，你会得到帕姆装扮的特写镜头。我们会讲到那里的。我有时间码。那是什么意思？你的语气里有很多尖锐。我知道。我对这套衣服有很多想法。珍娜，你知道这个乒乓球故事情节是受我们编剧现实生活的启发吗？是的，他们在仓库里放了一张乒乓球桌，那些家伙过去经常玩。他们不仅在仓库里有乒乓球桌，编剧们还自己做了一张乒乓球桌。李和吉恩用一张普通的桌子做了一张乒乓球桌，就像帕姆在会议室里做的那样。她做了这张桌子。嗯，编剧们在得到真正的乒乓球桌之前就那样做了。所以这一切都像《使命召唤》的故事情节一样，是受我们编剧室里发生的事情的启发。
I totally remember that. Yes. And like you said, Angela, Pam turns the conference room table into a ping pong table. She closes the blinds. And she tells Jim, you have to practice. You have to practice so that you can beat Terrell. And she tells him about Kelly's smack talk. Mm-hmm. And he's like, all right, I'll do it.
我完全记得那个。是的。就像你说的，安吉拉，帕姆把会议室的桌子变成了乒乓球桌。她拉上百叶窗。她告诉吉姆，你必须练习。你必须练习，这样你才能打败达里尔。她告诉他关于凯利的刻薄话。嗯。他说，好吧，我会做的。
But I did love how Jim immediately was like, oh, I can't beat Daryl. No, that's not happening. Back at corporate Michael meets Diane Kelly, the corporate legal counselor, who was played by Holly, Holly Maples. You might recognize her from the show In Plain Sight. She played Eleanor Prince. And he also finds out that Toby is going to be present for his deposition. Yeah.
但我确实喜欢吉姆立刻说，哦，我打不过达里尔。不，那是不可能的。回到公司，迈克尔见到了黛安·凯利，公司法律顾问，由霍莉·梅普尔斯饰演。你可能从《灵书妙探》这部剧中认出她。她饰演埃莉诺·普林斯。他还发现托比将出席他的取证会。是的。
And he says, I want him gone. I don't talk until he leaves. And they're like, Toby. is here as your representative, Michael. Well, then Michael is sworn in. Jenna, I have to share this. I have to share. Right as he's sworn in, there was a deleted scene that didn't make it in. That is so good.
他说，我不想见到他。他不走我就不说话。他们说，托比是作为你的代表在这里的，迈克尔。好吧，然后迈克尔宣誓就职。珍娜，我必须分享这个。我必须分享。就在他宣誓时，有一个被删减的场景没有放进去。那太棒了。
Michael stands up to the room and says, I have an opening statement. Oh, my God. Are you serious? Yes, it's so good. He does this whole heartfelt opening statement to this room of just stoic. faces and they're like, what is he doing? And he does it as if he's in a legal drama, like television show, like all the movies he's ever watched about lawyers, every TV show, he makes an opening statement, a plea to the jury, to the judge. Like, it's so ridiculous. It's wonderful. It's
迈克尔站起来对房间说，我有一个开场白。哦，天哪。你是认真的吗？是的，太棒了。他对着满屋子面无表情的人做了一个深情的开场白，他们就像，他在做什么？他做得好像他在一部法律剧里，就像电视节目，就像他看过的所有关于律师的电影，每一个电视节目，他做了一个开场白，向陪审团，向法官恳求。这太荒谬了。太精彩了。它在
in the deleted scenes. All right, Angela, please tell me that you're going to play this clip. Sam, can you play Michael's opening statement? Continue, I would like to make an opening statement. Fine. Please be brief. Ladies and gentlemen of the table, I would just like to say what a joy it is for me to be here today. But frankly, at my age, it's a joy to be anywhere. I'm only 44, so I'm not old, and I guess that doesn't really play. But the point is, I have a sense of humor, and I implore you all to have a sense of
被删减的场景里。好吧，安吉拉，请告诉我你要播放这个片段。萨姆，你能播放迈克尔的开场白吗？继续，我想做一个开场白。好吧。请简短点。桌子前的女士们先生们，我只想说今天能在这里是我的荣幸。但坦率地说，在我这个年纪，能在任何地方都是一种荣幸。我才44岁，所以我并不老，我想这并不好笑。但重点是，我有幽默感，我恳求你们所有人也有幽默感。
as well. Jan, David, my wonderful girlfriend, my gorgeous company. Why don't we all just take a big deep breath and just relax? Good. That feels good. All right. Everybody feel better? I don't know where to begin. He tries to do a joke. It doesn't land. one is looking at him like, like they're dead inside. You know what I mean? They have that kind of gaze. And then he's like, okay, that didn't play. Then he implores them to have a sense of humor. It's a deposition. Should we talk about his testimony? One thing I would like to point out, as Jan does her talking head at six minutes, 35 seconds. You know corporate has a name for their conference room, Jenna? Did you know that? What? Yeah, corporate's conference room has a plaque. It has a
同样。简，大卫，我出色的女朋友，我华丽的公司。我们为什么不都深呼吸一下，放松一下呢？好。感觉不错。好了。大家都感觉好点了吗？我不知道从哪里开始。他试图讲个笑话。没成功。每个人都看着他，就像，就像他们内心已经死了。你知道我的意思吗？他们有那种凝视。然后他说，好吧，那没奏效。然后他恳求他们有幽默感。这是一次取证会。我们应该谈谈他的证词吗？有一件事我想指出，当简在6分35秒做她的访谈时。你知道公司给他们的会议室起了一个名字吗，珍娜？你知道吗？什么？是的，公司的会议室有一块牌匾。它有一个
name. Do you want to hear it? What? It is the Robert Mifflin Memorial Conference Room. Is that hanging on a plaque over Jan's shoulder? Yes. Great catch. Thank you. I love me. The plaques on the walls, guys. As Michael's testimony begins, he very quickly gives a that's what she said joke. And it completely derails the deposition because the lawyers take everything literally. They're like, who said that? Who is she? Who is she? And what did she say? Here's the question the lawyer asked. And you were directly under her the entire time, Michael. That's what she said. Amazing. All of their line of questioning to Michael was so good. At seven minutes, eight seconds. The lawyer says, how long have you known the plaintiff? And Michael says, I haven't actually seen it. But I have seen the firm. And I am planning on renting the Pelican brief. Oh, my God. By the way, I don't think John Grisham has a book called The Plaintiff. He should.
名字。你想听吗？什么？它是“罗伯特·米夫林纪念会议室”。那块牌匾挂在简的肩膀上吗？是的。抓得好。谢谢。我爱我自己。墙上的牌匾，伙计们。当迈克尔的证词开始时，他很快就讲了一个“那是她说的”笑话。这完全破坏了取证会，因为律师们把一切都当真了。他们就像，谁说的？她是谁？她说了什么？这是律师问的问题。你一直直接在她下面，迈克尔。那是她说的。太棒了。他们对迈克尔的所有提问都太好了。在7分8秒。律师说，你认识原告多久了？迈克尔说，我实际上没见过它。但我见过这家公司。我正打算租《鹈鹕案件》。哦，天哪。顺便说一句，我不认为约翰·格里沙姆有一本书叫《原告》。他应该有的。
It's called The Client. That's right. It's not, I read them all, I want you to know. I really appreciated in this whole episode, I really appreciated the callbacks. Yes, they were so well thought out. A big one comes up in this scene when Michael displays. his document that he signed for HR, his love document, it's a callback from cocktails because it's in a frame. Michael said he was going to frame it and he did. There it is. Framed. And he didn't
它叫《委托人》。没错。不是，我全读过，我想让你知道。我非常欣赏这一整集，我非常欣赏那些呼应。是的，它们考虑得太周到了。在这个场景中出现了一个大的呼应，当迈克尔展示他为人力资源签署的文件，他的“爱情文件”时，这是对《鸡尾酒会》的呼应，因为它在一个框架里。迈克尔说他要把它装裱起来，他确实做了。就在那儿。装裱好了。而且他没有
bother to take it out of the frame to bring it to the deposition. He brought it in the frame. Also, Angela, at 8 minutes 48 seconds, there is a super cool Dunder Mifflin mug on the table in front of Michael. Did you see it? It's black with silver letters. I did see it and I thought, well, fancy corporate has fancy mugs. I want this mug. I don't think they ever did merch of this mug. What a missed opportunity. It's a classy mug. I loved it. Yeah, we never got one. No, we always got the white mug with the blue letters. I want the corporate mug with the silver letters, please. Michael has one line, Jenna, that I had to write down.
费心把它从框架里拿出来带到取证会。他带着框架把它带来了。另外，安吉拉，在8分48秒，迈克尔面前的桌子上有一个超级酷的邓德·米夫林马克杯。你看到了吗？它是黑色的，有银色的字母。我确实看到了，我想，嗯，时髦的公司有时髦的马克杯。我想要这个马克杯。我不认为他们出过这个马克杯的周边。真是错失良机。这是一个很有格调的马克杯。我喜欢它。是的，我们从来没得到过一个。不，我们总是得到带有蓝色字母的白色马克杯。我想要带有银色字母的公司马克杯，拜托。迈克尔有一句台词，珍娜，我不得不写下来。
Eight minutes, 28 seconds. To be delicate, the hang off my lady's chest. Oh, his whole description of Jan's breasts, you know, when he's trying to explain that he thinks she got fired because she got breast implants. But he won't just say that sentence. He says it's because of the twins. They hang off my lady's chest. To be delicate. They make milk.
8分28秒。为了委婉一点，挂在我女士胸前的那些。哦，他对他描述简的乳房的整个过程，你知道，当他试图解释他认为她被解雇是因为她做了隆胸手术时。但他不会只说那句话。他说是因为“双胞胎”。它们挂在我女士的胸前。为了委婉一点。它们产奶。
And they're like, what is this guy talking about? All right, this deposition is going to continue, but I do think we need to check in on the folks back in Scranton. Pam has gone around and has been recruiting people to practice ping pong in the conference room with the gym. She gets Kevin to go in there by saying Jim needs help, processing his travel receipts? Well, this completely confuses Angela and Oscar because you would never ask Kevin to do this. At 6 minutes, 58 seconds, there is a shot of Angela and Oscar looking very suspicious. Why is Kevin being called to do anything? The shot is cropped so high, Jenna, that you don't see my belly.
他们就像，这家伙在说什么？好吧，这次取证会将继续，但我确实认为我们需要看看斯克兰顿的人们。帕姆到处招募人去会议室和吉姆练习乒乓球。她让凯文进去，说吉姆需要帮助处理他的差旅费收据？嗯，这完全让安吉拉和奥斯卡感到困惑，因为你永远不会让凯文做这种事。在6分58秒，有一个安吉拉和奥斯卡看起来非常怀疑的镜头。为什么凯文被叫去做任何事？这个镜头裁剪得太高了，珍娜，你没看到我的肚子。
And also, baby jazz poster is there. Still there. Still there. Hmm. You and Oscar have worked something out in regard to the baby jazz poster. We'll never know. We never know. But it's made it back on the wall.
而且，“宝贝爵士”海报也在那里。还在那里。还在那里。嗯。你和奥斯卡在“宝贝爵士”海报方面达成了一致。我们永远不会知道。我们永远不会知道。但它又回到了墙上。
I love the scene with Kelly and Pam in the doorway to the bathroom. Pam's leaving the bathroom. Kelly's entering the bathroom and they meet in the doorway. Who is going to let the other go by? Now, of course, custom would have it that you let a person exit, right? Same with elevators. Let the people get off before you push on. Yes, that's social etiquette.
我喜欢凯利和帕姆在洗手间门口的那个场景。帕姆正要离开洗手间。凯利正要进入洗手间，她们在门口相遇。谁会让对方先过？现在，当然，习俗是你会让一个人先出来，对吧？电梯也是一样。让人先出来，然后再挤进去。是的，那是社交礼仪。
Yeah. But there's a standoff. So Pam moves aside. And Kelly's like, yeah, that's what I thought. Kelly is so, like, aggressive in this whole episode. She's just, like, hardcore. She's working some stuff out. Clearly.
是的。但这是一个僵局。所以帕姆让开了。凯利就像，是的，我就知道。凯利在这一整集中表现得太，就像，咄咄逼人了。她就像，强硬派。她正在解决一些事情。很明显。
Before we go back to the deposition and discuss my favorite moment from this entire episode, I think we should take a break. What is your favorite moment? I don't know. Okay, wait. I'll wait till after the break. Okay, okay. Let me just say the star of this episode is stenographer. Oh, yeah. Okay, I know the one. All right. We'll be back. We are back. And Angela, during the break, I asked Sam to please pull this clip of the stenographer reading back some of Michael's testimony.
在我们回到取证会并讨论我这一整集中最喜欢的时刻之前，我想我们应该休息一下。你最喜欢的时刻是什么？我不知道。好吧，等等。我会等到休息之后。好的，好的。我只想说这一集的明星是速记员。哦，是的。好吧，我知道那个。好吧。我们会回来的。我们回来了。安吉拉，在休息期间，我让萨姆请调出速记员读回迈克尔的一些证词的片段。
Oh. So this happened right after a commercial break of the show, the first scene back. was just the stenographer reading. And it's so brilliant, Sam, will you play it? Mr. Scott, do you realize you just contradicted yourself? I did. Yes, you did. Can I go to the bathroom? No. I really have to. I've been drinking lots of water. You went five minutes ago. That wasn't to go to the bathroom. That was to get out of a question. You still have to answer it. First, can I go to the bathroom? No. She is perfection.
哦。所以这发生在节目的广告休息之后，回来的第一个场景。只是速记员在读。这太精彩了，萨姆，你能播放吗？斯科特先生，你意识到你刚才自相矛盾了吗？我意识到了。是的，你意识到了。我可以去洗手间吗？不行。我真的必须去。我喝了很多水。你五分钟前才去过。那不是去洗手间。那是为了逃避问题。你仍然必须回答它。首先，我可以去洗手间吗？不行。她是完美的。
Lady, we got so much mail about her. Caitlin F. Brittany T. Lindsay H. Sarah C. Who is the stenographer? She is fantastic. How in the world did she repeat those lines back to the room with a straight face? And her cadence is so perfect. Guys, her name is Valerie Ross. She most recently played the role of Eunice Simpson, O.J. Simpson's mom in American Crime Story. But let me tell you, she has done a ton of work as a dramatic actor. But I'm But I went to her webpage and in her biography on her website, which is amazing, by the way, guys, I'm going to put a swipe up to it in the stories because her life is amazing. But I discovered that she completed the two-year program at Second City in Chicago, famous improv comedy. That's the same place that Steve studied. She also did improv with eight pieces of gold in San Francisco.
女士，我们收到了很多关于她的邮件。凯特琳·F，布列塔尼·T，琳赛·H，莎拉·C。谁是速记员？她太棒了。她到底是怎么面无表情地把那些台词读回给房间的？而且她的节奏太完美了。伙计们，她的名字是瓦莱丽·罗斯。她最近在《美国犯罪故事》中饰演了尤妮斯·辛普森，O.J.辛普森的母亲。但我告诉你，她作为戏剧演员做了大量的工作。但我去了她的网页，在她的网站上的传记里，顺便说一句，这太棒了，伙计们，我会在故事里放一个向上滑动的链接，因为她的生活太棒了。但我发现她完成了芝加哥第二城（Second City）的两年课程，那是著名的即兴喜剧。那是史蒂夫学习的同一个地方。她还在旧金山的“八块金子”（Eight Pieces of Gold）做过即兴表演。
She did comedy at the comedy store. She worked all over Los Angeles and improv theater. And yet her resume is like all dramatic work. It was so fascinating to me. I also have a connection with her. We both had guest starring roles on the TV drama Cold Case, not in the same episode, but I found that interesting, Valerie and I. I really felt like in my deep dive of Valerie Ross
她在喜剧商店做过喜剧。她在洛杉矶各地的即兴剧院工作。然而她的简历全是戏剧作品。这对我来说太迷人了。我和她也有联系。我们都在电视连续剧《铁证悬案》中担任过客串角色，不是在同一集，但我发现这很有趣，瓦莱丽和我。我真的觉得在我对瓦莱丽·罗斯的深入研究中
that it pointed to something that our show was so great at, which was hiring people for the realism, which made it funnier than if someone played it for comedy. That is right. That's why it's so funny is because when you hear her read off the testimony, it's like every courtroom you've ever gotten to look at, right? I don't know. I did jury duty. Have you done jury duty? I did jury selection. I was not ultimately picked. But you sat on a jury? I sat on a jury. What was your case, can you say? First of all, I always get called for jury duty. And I don't know, gentlemen. What is it? I always get picked. There's only been one time that I haven't been picked. I sat on a case and it was a car theft case. Okay. I was the alternate and you still have to go every day, but you actually cannot weigh in when you go to deliberate the case. You're only there if someone doesn't show up and then you can say something. So I just had to sit there quietly as they deliberated. I couldn't say any of my opinions. It was very hard for me. Did they vote to? convict or acquit? Ac quit. Would that have been your choice?
它指向了我们节目非常擅长的一点，那就是为了真实感而雇佣演员，这比有人为了喜剧而表演要有趣得多。那是对的。这就是为什么它这么有趣，因为当你听到她读出证词时，就像你见过的每一个法庭一样，对吧？我不知道。我做过陪审员。你做过陪审员吗？我做过陪审员选拔。我最终没有被选中。但你坐在陪审团里过吗？我坐在陪审团里过。你的案子是什么，可以说吗？首先，我总是被叫去当陪审员。我不知道，先生们。这是怎么回事？我总是被选中。只有一次我没被选中。我坐在一个案子上，那是一起汽车盗窃案。好吧。我是候补，你仍然必须每天去，但你实际上不能在审议案件时发表意见。只有当有人没出现时你才会在那里，然后你可以说点什么。所以我只能安静地坐在那里，听他们审议。我不能说出我的任何意见。这对我来说很难。他们投票决定有罪还是无罪？无罪。那会是你的选择吗？
Yes. All right. So I maybe was making a lot of facial like responses as they talked. You know I don't have a poker face. But while I was in this case, they did have the stenographer read back some testimony. And this is exactly what it is. It's no nonsense. They just read it right back.
是的。好吧。所以我可能在他们说话时做了很多面部反应。你知道我没有扑克脸。但当我在这个案子中时，他们确实让速记员读回了一些证词。这正是它的样子。没有废话。他们只是把它读回来。
There's no intonation. It's just exactly how Val did it. Do you know the famous? story of Steve Corell showing up for jury duty? No. At the height of all of it, like 40-year-old Virgin, Steve's blowing up his faces on billboards everywhere. He got called for jury duty. And you know, when you go to jury duty, they ask you questions. You get a sort of interview in the court. What is your profession? Do you have anything about your life that might make you unable to deliberate this case fairly, all that kind of stuff.
没有语调。这正是瓦尔做的那样。你知道史蒂夫·卡瑞尔去当陪审员的著名故事吗？不知道。在这一切的高峰期，就像《四十岁的老处男》，史蒂夫正在走红，他的脸到处都是广告牌。他被叫去当陪审员。你知道，当你去当陪审员时，他们会问你问题。你在法庭上会接受一种面试。你的职业是什么？你的生活中有什么可能让你无法公平地审议这个案件的事情吗，所有这些东西。
Right. Well, they asked Steve what his job was, and he said, I am an actor. And the judge who did not recognize Steve said, do you do any other work as a day job? And he said, no, just the acting. And then he got placed on the jury. And he deliberated this, I believe it was some sort of civil case. Well, Jenna, the last time I went for jury duty, I think it's when Netflix had really kicked it into high gear for the office. And they went around and asked us each those questions, what is your occupation?
对。好吧，他们问史蒂夫他的工作是什么，他说，我是一名演员。那位没认出史蒂夫的法官说，你做其他工作作为日常工作吗？他说，不，只是演戏。然后他就被安排在陪审团里了。他审议了这个，我相信是某种民事案件。好吧，珍娜，我上次去当陪审员时，我想那是Netflix真正为《办公室》加大力度的时候。他们到处问我们每个人那些问题，你的职业是什么？
And I said, I'm an actor. And he said, have you ever acted on a law drama? The judge said this to me. I said, no. He said, you just stick to workplace comedies. That's very funny. I said yes, and the whole courtroom started laughing. Clearly, the judge had watched the office. I know a lot of people always are trying to do these tricks to get out of jury duty, but I would love to be on a jury. I think the whole thing is fascinating. Sign me up. You know, it seems great.
我说，我是一名演员。他说，你演过法律剧吗？法官对我说了这个。我说，没有。他说，你还是坚持演职场喜剧吧。那太搞笑了。我说是的，整个法庭都开始笑了。显然，法官看过《办公室》。我知道很多人总是试图用这些技巧来逃避陪审义务，但我很乐意成为陪审员。我认为整个事情都很迷人。算我一个。你知道，这看起来很棒。
I think that's why I've been picked so many times before the office, because I actually show up with a notepad and a pin. I'm taking notes. And I think one side, either the person, prosecution, our defense is like, we need her. She's taken notes. Yeah. Well, in summary, Valerie Ross is the star of this episode. She's incredible. She's so good. I wanted more stenographer. You know what I could listen to? I could listen to her read all of Michael Scott's testimony. That would be a wonderful extra feature. Imagine if Val had read back his opening statement. Oh, my gosh. Oh, I want to contact her and see if she'll do it. That's amazing.
我想这就是为什么我在《办公室》之前被选中那么多次的原因，因为我实际上带着记事本和笔去。我在做笔记。我想一方，无论是控方还是辩方，都会想，我们需要她。她在做笔记。是的。总之，瓦莱丽·罗斯是这一集的明星。她太不可思议了。她太棒了。我想要更多的速记员。你知道我能听什么吗？我可以听她读完迈克尔·斯科特的所有证词。那将是一个很棒的额外功能。想象一下如果瓦尔读回了他的开场白。哦，天哪。哦，我想联系她看看她是否愿意做。那太棒了。
Should we go back to Scranton, Angela? Jim has just beaten Meredith at ping pong in the conference room, and Dwight busts in, and he demands to know what is going on in here. Well, Jim says he's got a big client that plays ping pong and he needs to, like, impress him. So Dwight's like, I'll help you, right? Yes. And he's got this talking head where Dwight says all of his heroes are table tennis players. Who knew? And he lists all of these names of actual people.
我们应该回到斯克兰顿吗，安吉拉？吉姆刚刚在会议室里打败了梅雷迪斯，德怀特闯了进来，他要求知道这里发生了什么。嗯，吉姆说他有一个大客户打乒乓球，他需要，就像，打动他。所以德怀特说，我会帮你的，对吧？是的。他有一个访谈，德怀特说他所有的英雄都是乒乓球运动员。谁知道呢？他列出了所有这些真实人物的名字。
And in the commentary, Rain shared that they actually put those names on a cue card for him, a big cue card, so that he didn't have to memorize them and he was able to read them off. Well, I'll tell you what, Angela, we had a fan catch. What? From Macy Gessler, who said, you can see a white square in the reflection. No. Of Rain's glasses during that talking head. That is the reflection.
在评论音轨中，雷恩分享说他们实际上把那些名字写在提示卡上给他，一张大提示卡，这样他就不必背下来，他就能读出来。好吧，我告诉你，安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝发现了。什么？来自梅西·格斯勒，她说，你可以在雷恩眼镜的反射中看到一个白色的方块。不。在那个访谈期间。那是提示卡的反射。
of the cue card. That is such a great catch. Mm-hmm. And I paused and I looked at it and sure enough it's there. Really? Ah, dang, I got to go back and look at that. That's so good. Big moment happening over at corporate.
那真是个伟大的发现。嗯。我暂停了，我看了看，果然在那里。真的吗？啊，该死，我得回去看看那个。太棒了。公司那边发生了大事。
The deposition is going off the rails because this is when there's a lot of questioning about when did Jan and Michael's relationship really begin. And Michael has testified to one thing and they try to prove him wrong by showing this picture of Jan on the beach in Jamaica, call back to back from vacation that Michael accidentally sent to everyone, as proof that their relationship started before the love document says it did. Jan's lawyer says that photo actually isn't proof,
取证会正在失控，因为这是有很多关于简和迈克尔的关系真正开始于何时的问题的时候。迈克尔作证说了一件事，他们试图通过展示这张简在牙买加海滩的照片来证明他是错的，这是对迈克尔不小心发给每个人的度假照片的呼应，作为证明他们的关系在“爱情文件”所说的时间之前就开始了。简的律师说那张照片实际上不是证据，
and we have Michael's journal to prove it. And Michael is like, what? Jan brought Michael's personal journal and they begin to read out of it. It's so embarrassing for Michael. Well, he's written all about his trip to Jamaica with Jan. And it's written like a 13-year-old boy wrote it. It's written, Jenna, the way I would write in my journal like when I was eight years old, dear diary. And then at the end I'd be like, XO, XO. XO. Like, what am I? Is the diary a person? Yeah. So it's like that or it's like, writing about meeting Patrick Dempsey. Very similar. You know Jen and I journal. You guys, you know this right. We shared the Patrick Dempsey Journal on this podcast. Yes, we're big
我们有迈克尔的日记来证明它。迈克尔就像，什么？简带来了迈克尔的个人日记，他们开始读它。这对迈克尔来说太尴尬了。嗯，他写了他和简去牙买加旅行的所有事情。而且写得像一个13岁的男孩写的。珍娜，写得就像我八岁时在日记里写的那样，亲爱的日记。然后在最后我会写，XO，XO。XO。就像，我是什么？日记是一个人吗？是的。所以就像那样，或者就像，写关于遇见帕特里克·德姆西。非常相似。你知道简和我也写日记。伙计们，你们知道这个，对吧。我们在播客上分享了帕特里克·德姆西日记。是的，我们是写日记的大户。
journalers. I counted actually how many journals I have. I don't even think I could count. I've got it over two dozen. I mean, so many. So many. I have 15. Oh, wow. Well, you know, lady, I did The Artist's Way. It's a 12-week self-led creativity seminar in a book. It's amazing if you're an artist. But it requires you to journal three pages every single morning, first thing. So I have legal pads and legal pads of these handwritten journals from when I did the Artist's Way. And I did the Artist's Way twice because the first time I didn't finish it.
我实际上数了我有多少本日记。我甚至不认为我能数得过来。我有超过两打。我是说，太多了。太多了。我有15本。哦，哇。嗯，你知道，女士，我做了《艺术家之路》。这是一本12周的自导创意研讨会书。如果你是艺术家，它太棒了。但它要求你每天早上第一件事就写三页日记。所以我有很多这些手写日记的法律垫，当我做《艺术家之路》时。而且我做了两次《艺术家之路》，因为第一次我没完成。
So I have like so much journal. Here is the journal entry that Jan's lawyer reads. I quote from an entry date of January 4 of this past year. Just got back from Jamaica. Tan almost everywhere. Jan almost everywhere. He he. Oh, diary, what a week.
所以我有很多日记。这是简的律师读的日记条目。我引用去年1月4日的条目。刚从牙买加回来。几乎到处都晒黑了。简几乎到处都是。嘻嘻。哦，日记，多么棒的一周。
I had sex with my boss. I don't know if it's going to go anywhere. Jan was very specific that it is not going anywhere, that it was a one-time mistake. But we had sex six times, so you tell me, I am definitely feeling very iry. But he says eerie and then Michael corrects him. Oh, more tomorrow. XO, XO, Michael.
我和我的老板发生了性关系。我不知道它会不会有结果。简非常明确地说它不会有结果，那是一次性的错误。但我们发生了六次性关系，所以你告诉我，我绝对感觉非常“irie”。但他说是“eerie”（怪异），然后迈克尔纠正了他。哦，明天再说。XO，XO，迈克尔。
Incredible. Angela, I looked up the definition of Irie. You did? Yeah. The lawyer thinks he meant eerie, but Michael's like, it's Irie. He's been in Jamaica. Yes. And it means nice, good, or pleasing, and it is used as a general term of approval in Jamaican English. So despite everything, he's feeling pretty iry. I have to say, Michael is absolutely crushed and feels betrayed by this reading of his journal. It is embarrassing and he is right to feel that way. Jan is horrible. This was horrible and this was premeditated. Yeah. She brought it from their home. Now they decide we're going to make copies of the journal.
不可思议。安吉拉，我查了“Irie”的定义。你查了？是的。律师认为他指的是“eerie”，但迈克尔说，是“Irie”。他一直在牙买加。是的。它的意思是好、棒或令人愉悦，在牙买加英语中被用作一般的赞同术语。所以尽管发生了一切，他感觉相当“irie”。我不得不说，迈克尔完全崩溃了，并因为读了他的日记而感到被背叛。这很尴尬，他有理由那样感觉。简太可怕了。这太可怕了，而且这是预谋的。是的。她从他们家里带来的。现在他们决定我们要复印日记。
We're going to make 10 copies. Toby's like, actually make it 11. Michael is just sinking further and further into this like embarrassing spiral. And Lester talked on the DVD commentary about one of the challenges of writing this episode was taking Michael through these layers, right? At the beginning of the deposition, he's feeling confident. And slowly with each layer, it's just all falling apart. It's hard to believe that it's going to get worse from here. and yet it does. It's so tragic. And now they go to lunch and everyone in this corporate lunchroom
我们要复印10份。托比说，实际上复印11份。迈克尔正越来越深地陷入这种尴尬的螺旋中。莱斯特在DVD评论中谈到编写这一集的一个挑战是让迈克尔经历这些层面，对吧？在取证会开始时，他感觉很自信。慢慢地，随着每一层，一切都在分崩离析。很难相信从这里开始会变得更糟。然而它确实变得更糟了。太悲剧了。现在他们去吃午饭，这个公司午餐室里的每个人
is reading his journal. All I could think of was corporate has a cafeteria? I believed it, Jenna, because you know those big buildings in New York? I do. They have cafeterias and food areas. Lady, I love a corporate cafeteria. I'll tell you what. I only experienced it once. when I worked at the Coca-Cola bottling company in Los Angeles. It's where they bottle the soda. I worked on the complaint hotline there. You did? I did.
都在读他的日记。我能想到的就是公司有自助餐厅？我相信了，珍娜，因为你知道纽约那些大楼吗？我知道。他们有自助餐厅和食品区。女士，我喜欢公司自助餐厅。我告诉你。我只经历过一次。当我在洛杉矶的可口可乐装瓶公司工作时。那是他们装瓶苏打水的地方。我在那里的投诉热线工作。你做过？我做过。
I took all of the complaints. And basically the policy was anyone who called a complaint got free coupons for soda. I had to listen to all the complaints and log all the complaints. And then mail the coupons. That was my job. It's kind of off in a remote area, this factory. You get 30 minutes for lunch. There's nowhere to go, so you had to bring your lunch, or they had a corporate cafeteria.
我接了所有的投诉。基本上政策是任何打电话投诉的人都会得到免费的苏打水优惠券。我必须听所有的投诉并记录所有的投诉。然后邮寄优惠券。那是我的工作。这个工厂在一个偏远地区。你有30分钟吃午饭。没地方去，所以你必须带午饭，或者他们有一个公司自助餐厅。
And lady, all the soda was free. You could drink as much as you wanted all day. The fountain sodas were free. But I love a cafeteria. I don't know what it is about it. I liked it when I was in high school. I loved it in college. I love a cafeteria.
而且女士，所有的苏打水都是免费的。你整天想喝多少就喝多少。喷泉苏打水是免费的。但我喜欢自助餐厅。我不知道它有什么特别之处。我在高中时喜欢它。我在大学时喜欢它。我喜欢自助餐厅。
This is going to melt your brain for a moment. About a year and a half ago, I met my friend Derek Haas, who works on Chicago Fire, Chicago PD. He's like the showrunner creator. He's like amazing, talented writer. We went to college together. He's like, Ange, come have lunch. Let's catch up.
这会让你大脑瞬间融化。大约一年半前，我遇到了我的朋友德里克·哈斯，他在《芝加哥烈焰》、《芝加哥警署》工作。他是那种剧集主管创作者。他就像很棒、有才华的编剧。我们一起上大学。他说，安吉，来吃午饭。我们叙叙旧。
I'm like, awesome. He's like, you know, our offices are Universal Studio lot. I said, yeah. He was like, so come meet me. We'll go to the NBC Universal Commissary. I said, what? He said, have you never been? You're on an NBC show.
我说，太棒了。他说，你知道，我们的办公室在环球影城地块。我说，是的。他说，所以来见我。我们去NBC环球餐厅。我说，什么？他说，你从来没去过吗？你在NBC节目上。
I was like, no. We filmed over in this little soundstage in the middle of nowhere. He said, oh, yeah, NBC has an amazing commissary. What? Jenna, it looks like you're at the four seasons. I'm talking like fabric napkin. The water glasses that are the big glasses, you know, where your iced tea comes with like a lemon wedge. Yeah.
我说，没有。我们在偏僻的那个小摄影棚拍摄。他说，哦，是的，NBC有一个很棒的餐厅。什么？珍娜，看起来你就像在四季酒店。我是说像布餐巾。水杯是那种大杯子，你知道，你的冰茶配上一片柠檬的那种。是的。
Jenna, we never got the NBC commissary treatment, but it was really good. I also went there years, years later to have. lunch with Terry Weinberg, who is one of the executive producers of the office. She works on the lot. She invited me for lunch, the commissary. And I thought the same thing. I thought, wow. Greg could have chosen to have our show on the lot.
珍娜，我们从来没得到过NBC餐厅的待遇，但它真的很好。多年后我也去那里吃过。和特里·温伯格吃午饭，她是《办公室》的执行制片人之一。她在那个地块工作。她邀请我去餐厅吃午饭。我想到了同样的事情。我想，哇。格雷格本可以选择让我们的节目在地块上拍摄。
But he wanted us to be more independent and have our own space, which ultimately I loved and was the right decision. Except for that damn cafeteria. I mean, I would have really liked that. That cafeteria was legit. This is not to say that we didn't have the greatest food on our set because our caterers were amazing. I just really like a cafeteria experience. It's not the food necessarily.
但他希望我们更独立，有我们自己的空间，最终我喜欢这个决定，这是正确的决定。除了那个该死的自助餐厅。我是说，我真的会很喜欢那个。那个自助餐厅是合法的。这并不是说我们的片场没有最好的食物，因为我们的餐饮服务商太棒了。我只是真的很喜欢自助餐厅的体验。不一定是食物。
I love the tray and you go down the little thing with the silver bars. You know, I love a soup plantation. This is why, I think. Lady, you don't have to even talk about this with me. You've heard my thoughts on a Vegas buffet. I know. It's just things we like. Guess where we filmed these corporate cafeteria scenes.
我喜欢托盘，你沿着那个带银色栏杆的小东西走。你知道，我喜欢“汤种植园”。这就是为什么，我想。女士，你甚至不需要和我谈这个。你听过我对拉斯维加斯自助餐的想法。我知道。这只是我们喜欢的东西。猜猜我们在哪里拍摄这些公司自助餐厅场景。
I know, but I'm not going to say, you tell us. At the Universal Studios Commissary! So crazy, we filmed them for one day. We rented the entire space so everyone who is working there didn't get to eat lunch there that day. Because all the people in the background were hired by us for non-speaking roles, we had that cafeteria that day to shoot these lunch scenes. Well, Jenna, Michael is walking around the cafeteria and he doesn't know where to sit. Everyone's reading his journal. He's feeling a bit lost. And you know he's at the bottom of the barrel when he goes and sits with Toby.
我知道，但我不会说，你告诉我们。在环球影城餐厅！太疯狂了，我们拍了一天。我们租了整个空间，所以所有在那里工作的人那天都没能在那里吃午饭。因为背景里的所有人都是我们雇佣的非台词角色，我们那天有那个自助餐厅来拍摄这些午餐场景。嗯，珍娜，迈克尔在自助餐厅走来走去，他不知道坐在哪里。每个人都在读他的日记。他感觉有点迷茫。你知道当他去和托比坐在一起时，他已经到了谷底。
And Toby tries. Toby is so kind. Yeah. He brings up his parents' divorce and how it made him feel. Both of his parents wanted him to testify. And he's like, but I just love them both so much. Yeah. And he's sort of saying, Michael, I know you love Jan and you loved Dunder Mifflin. So I see how you. you're pulled in two directions too. That's the subtext. Michael responds by pushing Toby's tray onto the floor and his entire lunch goes with it. So Lester talked about this moment. He said in the script they had written where Michael just goes off on Toby, like makes a big speech. And they filmed it that way. And then Paul Lieberstein pitched, hey, why don't we do one take where he just shoves my tray off the table and walks away and doesn't even respond to me? And they did it. It was just like,
托比尝试了。托比太善良了。是的。他提到了他父母的离婚以及这让他感觉如何。他的父母都想让他作证。他说，但我只是太爱他们俩了。是的。他有点在说，迈克尔，我知道你爱简，你也爱邓德·米夫林。所以我明白你是如何被拉向两个方向的。那是潜台词。迈克尔的回应是把托比的托盘推到地板上，他的整个午餐也随之而去。所以莱斯特谈到了这个时刻。他说在剧本里他们写了迈克尔对托比发火，就像做了一个大演讲。他们那样拍了。然后保罗·利伯斯坦提议，嘿，为什么我们不拍一个镜头，他只是把我的托盘从桌子上推开，走开，甚至不回应我？他们做了。这就像，
in the moment, idea in the moment, and that's what made it in. So good. It's so funny. When the deposition continues, they are still reading Michael's diary. They have some questions. They say, who is this other woman, Ryan, who you refer to? Oh, no. Toby cannot keep his composure. He is cracking up. Michael just so looks up to Ryan. And, his admiration of Ryan is one of my favorite little tidbits of the show. Well, he has a man crush on him. And, you know, Ryan got to do all the things I think Michael had hoped for. He went to college.
当下的想法，当下的想法，这就是最终放进去的内容。太棒了。太搞笑了。当取证会继续时，他们还在读迈克尔的日记。他们有一些问题。他们说，这个你提到的叫瑞恩的其他女人是谁？哦，不。托比无法保持镇定。他笑得前仰后合。迈克尔就是那么仰慕瑞恩。而且，他对瑞恩的钦佩是我最喜欢的节目小花絮之一。嗯，他对他有男性的迷恋。而且，你知道，瑞恩得到了所有我认为迈克尔希望得到的东西。他上了大学。
He got his MBA. He's at corporate now. He represents something to Michael that Michael always hoped to have. Yeah. That kind of status. And now they're going to start reading from Jan's performance review of Michael, which we find out she wrote after they were together. Oh. And her comments are so harsh and mean, really mean. She recommends that he be let go from the company. She's out of carrots. She's out of sticks. Yeah. Nothing works with Michael and that he's best suited for sales, which by the way, Jenna, I don't think she's wrong. I don't think she's wrong either. But this guts, Michael. Yeah. He said, you expect to get screwed by your company, but you don't expect to get screwed by your company. But you don't expect to get screwed.
他拿到了MBA。他现在在公司。他代表了迈克尔一直希望拥有的东西。是的。那种地位。现在他们要开始读简对迈克尔的绩效评估，我们发现那是他们在在一起之后写的。哦。她的评论太刺耳和刻薄了，真的很刻薄。她建议他被公司解雇。她没招了。她没招了。是的。迈克尔什么都不管用，他最适合销售，顺便说一句，珍娜，我不认为她错了。我不认为她错了。但这让迈克尔崩溃了。是的。他说，你期望被你的公司搞砸，但你不期望被你的公司搞砸。但你不期望被搞砸。
by your girlfriend. We got some mail. We did. This is from Lou Chen, who says, as a lawyer who's taken depositions, I felt that the Michael deposition, as depicted in this episode, was impressively true to life while still being hilarious. And Kate P. and Peter W. pointed out something I thought was very interesting. Why didn't they use the documentary film footage for proof in the deposition?
被你的女朋友。我们收到了一些邮件。我们收到了。这是来自卢·陈，他说，作为一名进行过取证的律师，我觉得这一集中描绘的迈克尔取证会令人印象深刻地真实，同时仍然非常搞笑。凯特·P和彼得·W指出了我认为非常有趣的一点。为什么他们不在取证会中使用纪录片拍摄的镜头作为证据？
Oh. Oh, interesting. Yes. Interesting. They would have. They could have. Yeah. We could see a lot of stuff on tape.
哦。哦，有趣。是的。有趣。他们会有的。他们本可以的。是的。我们可以看到磁带上的很多东西。
They didn't ask. Hmm. But they agreed to have the cameras in the room. Yes. So interesting. Well, you know, Jenna, in the deleted scenes, there's a moment, you know, where Michael's like, listen, she didn't mean it. She was going through a divorce at the time. she was drinking a lot.
他们没问。嗯。但他们同意让摄像机在房间里。是的。太有趣了。嗯，你知道，珍娜，在被删减的场景里，有一个时刻，你知道，迈克尔就像，听着，她不是故意的。她当时正在经历离婚。她喝了很多酒。
And then Jan makes a face, right? And then Michael goes, of water because she was taking all of those pills. He just keeps revealing all of the stuff that's making it worse and worse. And they had to trim some of that for time. But I just loved it. Ladies, speaking of water, do you know how much water Tom Brady drinks every day? What? Yeah.
然后简做了一个表情，对吧？然后迈克尔说，水，因为她正在吃所有那些药。他只是不断揭露所有让事情变得越来越糟的东西。他们不得不为了时间剪掉一些。但我就是喜欢它。女士们，说到水，你知道汤姆·布雷迪每天喝多少水吗？什么？是的。
Tom Brady. Where is this coming from? It's coming from the fact that the Super Bowl was recently. Yeah. And Tom Brady won. Yeah. And he looks like he's still 24. And I became a little obsessed with his athletic ability.
汤姆·布雷迪。这是从哪里来的？这是因为超级碗最近刚结束。是的。汤姆·布雷迪赢了。是的。他看起来仍然像24岁。我变得有点沉迷于他的运动能力。
And I read, and this is common knowledge, apparently, Lee was like, welcome to Tom Brady, Jenna. Thanks for. I don't know it. What is it? He has this very, very, very strict diet that he adheres to. He has a personal chef and he eats this mostly plant-based diet, but it also involves drinking gallons and gallons and gallons of water a day, like half his body weight in water.
我读到，这显然是常识，李就像，欢迎来到汤姆·布雷迪，珍娜。谢谢。我不知道。是什么？他有这种非常、非常、非常严格的饮食，他坚持执行。他有一个私人厨师，他吃这种主要是植物性的饮食，但也包括每天喝加仑加仑加仑的水，就像他体重一半的水。
And all I could think about was, number one, this is such a great advertisement for drinking water. But number two, how does he make it through a whole football game without having to pee constantly? How does he do it? I drink eight glasses of water a day and I feel like all I do is pee. How does he drink so much water? And every time now, ever since learning this, that anyone brings up water, I think of Tom Brady.
我能想到的就是，第一，这对喝水来说是一个很好的广告。但第二，他是怎么在不经常小便的情况下完成整场橄榄球比赛的？他是怎么做到的？我每天喝八杯水，我觉得我所做的就是小便。他怎么喝那么多水？现在每次，自从学到这个，任何人提到水，我就想到汤姆·布雷迪。
Well, maybe he does pee during a game. Maybe it just goes down his leg. I mean, you would never know. Oh, my God. Angela. Listen, I would have thought that was crazy until, you know, Josh, who played soccer. Josh was a big soccer player all through high school and he played in college. And he said, listen to this.
嗯，也许他在比赛中确实小便了。也许它只是顺着他的腿流下来了。我是说，你永远不会知道。哦，天哪。安吉拉。听着，我会认为那很疯狂，直到，你知道，踢足球的乔希。乔希在高中时是一名伟大的足球运动员，他在大学里踢球。他说，听着这个。
He said on a soccer field during a long game, Sometimes you can just like take a knee and whip it out to the side and just pee for a second. So those soccer games, the guys are peeing. So when they're like they're pretending to maybe lace their shoe or something? Yeah, yeah. They just flop it out and take a whiz. But football players wear super tight pants and stuff. I feel like you would see it.
他说在足球场上一场漫长的比赛中，有时你可以就像跪下来，把它甩到一边，小便一秒钟。所以那些足球比赛，男人们在小便。所以当他们就像假装可能系鞋带什么的？是的，是的。他们只是把它掏出来，撒泡尿。但橄榄球运动员穿超级紧的裤子什么的。我觉得你会看到的。
No, you wouldn't. It's all padded. You wouldn't see it. I bet they can pee in their pants. Oh my gosh. I need to know. Football players, someone write in. Have you ever peed during a game and did anyone know? Also, person who interviews Tom Brady next about his diet and about his water consumption, will you please ask him about this? Because I need to understand when and how often the man goes to
不，你不会的。那里面全是衬垫。你根本看不出来。我敢打赌他们能在裤子里尿尿。天哪。我需要知道。橄榄球运动员们，有人写信来吧。你们在比赛中尿过尿吗？有人知道吗？还有，下次采访汤姆·布雷迪关于他的饮食和饮水量的人，能请你问问他这个问题吗？因为我需要了解这个男人什么时候去，以及多久去一次
the bathroom. I need to know. This seems unmanageable. Here's my takeaway. Don't go on a road trip with Tom Brady unless you like making lots of stops. If we want to continue the Tom Brady tangent, I remember one time Lee and I read about the new house that he and Giselle purchased and it was humongous and it had like a gazillion rooms. And Lee said something that was so funny to me. He said, can you imagine if Tom Brady gets to the kitchen and he realizes he left his cell phone in the bedroom, how far he has to walk to get it? He's like, I get annoyed when I have to walk because I forgot something in another room.
洗手间。我需要知道。这看起来太难处理了。我的结论是：除非你喜欢频繁停车，否则不要和汤姆·布雷迪一起公路旅行。如果我们想继续汤姆·布雷迪的话题，我记得有一次李和我读到他和吉赛尔买的新房子，那房子大得惊人，有无数个房间。李说了一句让我觉得特别好笑的话。他说，你能想象如果汤姆·布雷迪走到厨房，发现手机落在卧室里，他得走多远才能拿回来吗？他说，我只要因为忘了东西在另一个房间而不得不走过去，就会觉得很烦。
But think of how far they have to walk. And it's always stuck with me because it's true. You know what they do? They go like this and someone goes and gets it for them. Oh, they have a staff. They have a staff. That's what it is. The butler gets it.
但想想他们得走多远。这句话一直印在我的脑海里，因为这是真的。你知道他们怎么做吗？他们就这样挥挥手，然后就有人去帮他们拿。哦，他们有员工。他们有员工。就是这样。管家会去拿。
Tom Brady doesn't walk back to his bedroom for his cell phone. he's too busy drinking water. He's too busy peeing. Speaking of outstanding feats of athleticism, back in the conference room, Dwight is beating Jim at ping pong. Dwight looks like he's barely making any effort to beat Jim. He's on his phone.
汤姆·布雷迪不会为了拿手机走回卧室。他忙着喝水呢。他忙着尿尿呢。说到出色的运动天赋，回到会议室，德怀特正在乒乓球比赛中打败吉姆。德怀特看起来几乎没费什么力气就打败了吉姆。他还在玩手机。
He can just hit the ball no matter what. And Pam comes in at 16 minutes, 21 seconds. Jenna, I'm going to show you your outfit. I took a screen grab up it. Oh, is it time? It's time because this is the moment. if you really want to see your outfit here. What is this outfit?
无论如何他都能打到球。帕姆在16分21秒时进来了。珍娜，我要给你看你的装扮。我截了图。哦，是时候了吗？是时候了，因为这就是那个时刻。如果你真的想看你的装扮的话。这是什么装扮？
What is your grape about this outfit? We have black tights, a long black skirt just below your knee, a blue buttoned up sweater. I'm just saying, Pam went through this phase in the beginning of her courtship with Jim where she was zushing herself up a little. And I think this outfit says, I am now comfortable in my relationship. Do without what you will. Well, I take it as an insult. It seems phrased that way.
你对这身装扮有什么不满？我们有黑色连裤袜，一条刚好过膝的黑色长裙，一件蓝色扣子毛衣。我只是说，帕姆在和吉姆恋爱的初期经历过这个阶段，当时她稍微打扮了一下自己。我觉得这身装扮在说，我现在在恋爱关系中很自在。随你怎么想吧。好吧，我把它当作一种侮辱。听起来确实是这样表达的。
I think maybe Pam is just a little cold. It's winter. She has exchanged her panty hose for tights, which is something we did for her in the winter months. But I don't think she has gotten comfortable in any way. She just had a day where maybe she didn't pair the right things together. That is all. I think you'll see.
我觉得也许帕姆只是有点冷。现在是冬天。她把连裤袜换成了紧身裤，这是我们在冬季为她做的。但我不觉得她有任何自在的感觉。她只是那天可能没把衣服搭配好。仅此而已。我想你会看到的。
In dinner party coming up, she's going to wear an adorable little cocktail dress. So don't worry. All right, I will back off Pam's attire. It did crack me up. I have an observation about this scene. Jim keeps saying spin serve. Spin serve. That is not a thing.
在接下来的晚宴那一集中，她会穿一件可爱的小鸡尾酒裙。所以别担心。好吧，我不评价帕姆的穿着了。这确实让我笑了。我对这个场景有一个观察。吉姆一直在说旋转发球。旋转发球。根本没这回事。
I looked it up. Spin is not reserved for a serve. And of the top five table tennis serves, only three of the five involve any spin. And I'll tell you what they are. Number one, the short side spin pendulum serve. Number two, the short side spin reverse pendulum serve. Mm-hmm.
我查过了。旋转并不是发球的专属。在乒乓球前五大发球中，只有三个涉及旋转。我来告诉你它们是什么。第一，短侧旋摆速发球。第二，短侧旋反向摆速发球。嗯。
Number three is the fast no-spin cross-serve. Number four is the fast no spin down the line serve. And number five is the long side spin serve. So there's no such thing as just spin serve. You have to be more specific, Jim. Is it a short side spin? Is it a pendulum? Is it a long side spin?
第三是快速无旋转交叉发球。第四是快速无旋转直线发球。第五是长侧旋发球。所以根本没有所谓的旋转发球。你得更具体一点，吉姆。是短侧旋吗？是摆速发球吗？是长侧旋吗？
And by the way, just because you're putting spin on it doesn't mean you're mastering the game because there's a couple of great serves that involve no spin at all. I don't know why I felt the need to put Jim in his place about this spin serve, but he was just saying it with such authority. And it's not a thing, Jim. It's not a thing. Well, don't tell my husband that because he thinks the spin serve is where it's at. He's going to spin it all.
顺便说一句，仅仅因为你加了旋转并不意味着你精通这项运动，因为有几个很棒的发球根本不涉及旋转。我不知道为什么我觉得有必要在这方面纠正吉姆，但他说话的语气太权威了。根本没这回事，吉姆。没这回事。好吧，别告诉我丈夫，因为他认为旋转发球才是王道。他会把球旋转着
on over. Listen, it's just that there needs to be more specificity. Well, I'm going to tell him that next time he's playing while I'm trying to eat at the ping pong table. Please do you. You put him in his place. Josh, that's not the long spin, side spin. Short spin. That's a short spin. There you go. Well, Jim says he's ready. I'm going to go play Daryl. Pam's so excited they go down to the warehouse. And right away, it's not going Jim's way. And Kelly starts doing all of of her smack talk, trash talk. She's making up a song, hey, hey, you, you, I don't like your boyfriend. She's doing a whole thing. Pam has had it. Yeah. She's like, you and me right now, we're going to play. And they are both horrible. We had a fan question. From Corinna O, Naomi Y, and Lizzie M. Are you and Mindy actually bad at ping pong or did you have to
发过来。听着，只是需要更具体一点。好吧，下次他在我试图在乒乓球桌上吃饭时玩的时候，我会告诉他的。请一定要这样做。你得纠正他。乔什，那不是长侧旋，侧旋。短旋。那是短旋。这就对了。好吧，吉姆说他准备好了。我要去和达里尔打球了。帕姆很兴奋，他们去了仓库。很快，事情就不顺吉姆的意了。凯利开始说垃圾话。她编了一首歌，嘿，嘿，你，你，我不喜欢你的男朋友。她做了一整套动作。帕姆受够了。是啊。她说，你和我，现在，我们要打一场。结果他们俩都烂透了。我们有一个粉丝提问。来自科琳娜·O，娜奥米·Y，和莉齐·M。你和敏迪真的不擅长打乒乓球，还是你们不得不
pretend. Let me say this. Mindy and I were not great at ping pong, but we weren't that bad at ping pong. So we were pretending to be that bad. And the point was that we would never get past a certain number of volleys. Are they called volleys in ping pong? You should know. Oh, I didn't get that far in my research. And also, I know that John is actually good at ping pong and he had to pretend to be not as good as he was. Yes. And by the way, we played a lot of ping pong while we were just waiting for various camera setups and things like that. This was a really fun day of shooting, actually, because we had this toy, which then stayed in the warehouse and we would play. Well, and there are a lot of deleted scenes of all the other office members playing ping pong that didn't make it in. Phyllis and Stanley play at the makeshift ping pong table up in the conference room. Meredith has a turn. I yell off camera. I'm next. So it's like everyone is getting in there to play ping pong. Lady, the deposition is almost over.
假装。让我这么说吧。敏迪和我乒乓球打得不算好，但也没那么差。所以我们是假装打得那么差。重点是我们永远不会超过一定数量的对打。乒乓球里叫对打吗？你应该知道。哦，我的研究还没到那一步。而且，我知道约翰乒乓球其实打得很好，他不得不假装没那么好。是的。顺便说一句，我们在等待各种摄像机设置的时候打了很多乒乓球。这其实是拍摄中非常有趣的一天，因为我们有这个玩具，它后来留在了仓库里，我们会玩。而且，还有很多其他办公室成员打乒乓球的删减片段没有放进去。菲利斯和斯坦利在会议室的临时乒乓球桌上打。梅雷迪斯也轮到了。我在镜头外大喊：下一个是我。所以每个人都参与进来打乒乓球了。女士，取证快结束了。
And it's so sad because they've read David Wallace's testimony about whether or not he was ever really going to hire Michael for this corporate position. And you can tell in the testimony that David is really struggling to admit this. But the truth is Michael was never a real contender. Yeah, David says, listen, come on. He's a nice guy. Yeah. And he didn't want to have to go on record saying truthfully, Michael isn't anyone he considered. But you know what's interesting is of all of that crushing information, what Michael heard was that David Wallace called him a nice guy.
太令人难过了，因为他们读了戴维·华莱士关于他是否真的打算雇佣迈克尔担任这个公司职位的证词。你可以从证词中看出戴维在承认这一点时非常挣扎。但事实是迈克尔从来都不是真正的竞争者。是的，戴维说，听着，拜托。他是个好人。是的。他不想在记录中说实话，即迈克尔不是他考虑的人选。但你知道有趣的是，在所有这些令人沮丧的信息中，迈克尔听到的是戴维·华莱士称他为好人。
Yeah. And when Jan's lawyer says, wouldn't you agree with Ms. Levinson that the company exhibits a pattern of disrespect towards its employees, Michael says, absolutely not. Yeah. He tanks her lawsuit. There goes the $4 million. Now they're only going to be able to get Chinese food for dinner. Oh, it's going to be a rough car ride home. But there is a very sweet scene where David Wallace goes up to Michael and is like, hey, I'm really sorry that you got drug into this. I never wanted that. And Michael's like, it's okay. There is this moment though, Jenna, where David is like the father Michael never had. And it looks like Michael is trying not to cry. Yeah. Like when your dad comes up to you and says, I'm sorry, buddy, you okay? It's like that moment. Yeah.
是的。当简的律师说，难道你不认同莱文森女士的观点，即公司对员工表现出一种不尊重的模式吗？迈克尔说，绝对不是。是的。他搞砸了她的诉讼。400万美元没了。现在他们晚餐只能吃中餐了。哦，回家的车程会很艰难。但有一个非常温馨的场景，戴维·华莱士走到迈克尔身边说，嘿，我很抱歉你被卷进这件事里。我从来没想过这样。迈克尔说，没关系。不过珍娜，有那么一刻，戴维就像迈克尔从未有过的父亲。看起来迈克尔在努力不哭。是的。就像你爸爸走过来对你说，对不起，伙计，你还好吗？就是那一刻。是的。
And Michael's like, for the record, I think you're a nice guy too. It's a really sweet scene. It is. I have a great little behind the scenes trivia for you for that car ride home with Michael and Jan. Ooh, tell me. Lester said that they had put lipstick cameras in the PT cruiser for that car ride home. Mm-hmm. and when they got the footage back, it was all just completely dark.
迈克尔说，郑重声明，我也觉得你是个好人。这是一个非常温馨的场景。确实。关于迈克尔和简回家的那段车程，我有一个很棒的幕后花絮要告诉你。哦，告诉我。莱斯特说他们在PT巡洋舰车里装了口红摄像机来拍摄那段回家的车程。嗯，当他们拿回录像时，全是黑的。
The little light that they had put in the car, like on the dashboard where you couldn't see it, it was going to illuminate Malora and Steve's faces. I guess there was something wrong with the light and it clicked off and all the footage was dark. Oh, no. So the only footage they had of that car ride scene was from the follow car that was in front of them, right? Yes. So they had a car in front of them filming them. filming them, and that's the only camera that worked. And I actually really like it. And they talked
他们装在车里的小灯，比如在仪表盘上你看不到的地方，本打算照亮马洛拉和史蒂夫的脸。我猜灯出了点问题，它关掉了，所有的录像都是黑的。哦，不。所以他们拥有的唯一那段车程的录像来自在他们前面的跟随车，对吧？是的。所以他们有一辆车在前面拍摄他们。拍摄他们，那是唯一工作的摄像机。我其实真的很喜欢它。他们谈论了
about this little bit in the commentary that it made it seem just way more real. That there was this distance between the camera and what was happening. Kind of like what Randall talked about when he was on. The further away you were, the more intimate the moment feels to the viewer. Absolutely. This episode ends with an epic ping pong match. between Dwight and Moes, who has left Shrewt farms, I believe for the first time, we're seeing him off the farm. They are playing ping pong in the warehouse. It's clearly after hours. It's dark. Not all the lights are on. And they are amazing. We had a fan question, Angela, from Ben S. Keith N., Bethany M. and Kai B.
在评论中提到这一点，它让一切看起来更真实。摄像机和正在发生的事情之间有这种距离感。有点像兰德尔在节目中谈到的。你离得越远，观众感受到的时刻就越亲密。绝对是。这一集以一场史诗般的乒乓球比赛结束，在德怀特和莫斯之间，我相信这是我们第一次看到他离开施鲁特农场。他们在仓库里打乒乓球。显然是下班后。天黑了。灯没全开。他们太棒了。安吉拉，我们有一个来自本·S、基思·N、贝瑟尼·M和凯·B的粉丝提问。
Were Rain and Mike Scher actually playing ping pong in this scene? Are they that good? good. No. No. This was all CGI. I think by this time they had learned how hard it was to actually film actors playing ping pong. So that was CGI. Yeah, those guys were just moving their arms and they put the ball in digitally in post. Before we wrap up this episode, you guys, there is a deleted scene that is delicious. It's Crete's turn to practice ping pong with Jim in the conference room at Dundermifflin. And Creed's like, yeah, I played. I learned to play in Cambodia. Jim's like, great. They start playing. Creed loses a point right out of the gate. Starts taking off his shirt. Jim's like, hold up. What's what's happening? And Creed's like, but this isn't strip pong? And Jim's like, no, no, no. Creed's like, okay. Wow. Creed thought when you play ping pong, you have to strip when you lose a point. Oh, that's funny. I wish that stayed in. I know. That's what she said. Guys, that is the deposition. I hope you will join us next week for some Osabuko dinner party.
雷恩和迈克·舒尔真的在这一幕里打乒乓球吗？他们真的那么厉害吗？不。不。这全是CGI。我想那时候他们已经知道拍摄演员打乒乓球有多难了。所以那是CGI。是的，那些家伙只是在移动手臂，他们在后期制作中用数字方式加上了球。在结束这一集之前，伙计们，有一个删减片段非常精彩。轮到克里德在邓德米夫林的会议室里和吉姆练习乒乓球了。克里德说，是的，我打过。我在柬埔寨学的。吉姆说，太好了。他们开始打。克里德一上来就输了一分。开始脱衬衫。吉姆说，等等。怎么了？克里德说，这不是脱衣乒乓球吗？吉姆说，不，不，不。克里德说，好吧。哇。克里德以为打乒乓球输一分就得脱一件衣服。哦，太搞笑了。我希望那段能保留下来。我知道。这就是她说的。伙计们，这就是取证。希望你们下周能加入我们，一起看《Osabuko》晚宴那一集。
Oh my God. Next week is dinner party. Yep. Holy crap sticks. Dinner party. We're here, Jenna. We'll show up for it, guys. I can't wait.
天哪。下周是晚宴。是的。天哪。晚宴。我们到了，珍娜。我们会准时参加的，伙计们。我等不及了。
I can't wait. All right. We'll see you then. Bye. Have a great week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
我等不及了。好吧。到时候见。再见。祝你们有愉快的一周。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jirkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制片人是卡西·吉尔金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。